representative hill the sponsor
uh good morning man chair and the rest
of uh edna committee
for the record i am representative greg
hill
i'm assuming everyone can hear me
so i see a couple of nods that's a good
thing um
for the record i'm also the
representative for uh the town of
northfield and one-third of the city of
franklin
um i'm here to talk to you about
an organization that's near and dear to
my heart since i've become a
representative back
10 years or so ago
and that's the legislative youth
advisory council
i hope you've all taken advantage of the
opportunity to attend one of their zoom
meetings
or maybe you have submitted legislation
for them to examine
and provide testimony on
i think you'll find that they're a great
bunch of kids
and
and i think they'll probably be our
replacements at some point in time here
um
this is uh
this is a very unusual group
and one that i think is worthy of our
attention
in preparation for this i re-read
the statutes dealing with legislative
youth advisory council they're available
in section 19-k
colon one two three and four
sounds ominous but you could probably
read it in the time that i take to
testify here
um
they it is very clear from from that
those statutes that the goal is to try
to create a diverse group of uh or a
cross section of new hampshire students
whether
that is by
geographic um or socioeconomic
or by the opportunities of where they
find their education whether they're
private schools or public schools or
charter schools or whatever
right to the workforce
so what we're hoping to do is try to get
as diverse a group as we can
and that's what i see
as a problem um
and what i was hoping to
deal with in this legislation
we currently have
four people appointing members to the
legislative youth advisory council that
would be the senate president the
speaker the governor and the
secretary of state
none of these four coordinate
so
it's just by chance
that we end up with a diverse group
or covering
as many of the possible
organizations or geographic uh areas as
we can
so
the proposal in this bill um primarily
is to
limit that down to two appointers
um and and recognizing that this is the
legislative youth advisory council it
would seem logical that the legislature
are the appointers so i've made the
senate president and uh and the speaker
the primary um appointers of the
students
um certainly the other two that i've uh
deleted off that list of appointers um
would be able to
suggest names to those people but i
think primarily um it would be a good
idea if the senate president and the
speaker coordinated
um in order to get as diverse a group as
possible
and and as you read the statutes i think
one of the things that's most evident is
that they talk about diversity in a
number of areas but they don't talk
about diversity of thought
and and that's
um i've been involved with this group
for a little over 10 years
that's one of the things that i'm seeing
that is a problem for me
it's become a less and less diverse
group in terms of thought
almost all of their
decisions uh on legislation
come down to a unanimous vote um
there used to be years ago
a real give and take a real
um pro and con you know
for those of us that remember 60 minutes
used to have point counterpoint um they
used to have those kind of discussions
and they were terrific uh theater to
watch
they don't do that anymore um it seems
that all of the students come from one
train of thought and um and they all
agree on on what the testimony would be
you can imagine and i think part of that
reason is um where they're appointed
from and i think the other reason is um
somewhere along the line someone has
come up with the idea of an application
and they're handing out the application
or the the current members take those
applications and give them to other
students that they know
and they give them to the students that
uh that think the way that they do um
they don't look for
you know someone that doesn't think the
way that they do and and so it becomes a
self-licking ice cream cone here you
know you you pretty much know the result
um when you come in
so
i would like to see
i think this bill
retained
and the reason is i it would give the
committee the ability to see some of
their their um council meetings in
action
um take some of the thoughts that i've
given you this morning and apply those
to those meetings i've had some nice
conversations with the members of of the
council um and they've come up with an
amendment that i think will be
introduced today
um they've had some great ideas um i
think those should be incorporated in in
some of the uh
work over the summer perhaps on this
group
but um more than anything else i'd like
this to be
the way the uh drafters originated
originally uh designed this it should be
a a give-and-take organization and it's
not become that um
so with that i'll end i'm happy to
answer any other questions about the
legislation that i proposed
um but i think it may be best served
for the state of new hampshire and for
the kids um if we
if we talk this over a little bit so
that's where i'll leave it
again happy to answer any questions
yes representative schuett has a
question
thank you madam chair good morning
representative hill
um i'm curious why
if you are concerned
about the current appointing
authorities why didn't you incorporate
the way so many of these things are
formed
by naming
groups or or persons to nominate
uh names to put forward to those
appointing authorities
uh thank you for your question and um
and if i could i would show you my notes
um that that says almost exactly that um
one of the things i thought i'd talk
about uh during the
study committee of some type
my idea was would be to use that um
that application process
by
asking the department of education to
to submit a single application to all of
their schools all of their contacts you
know all of the charter school
um
user groups um and have them create this
pool that the purpose of the application
process i believe
was to create a pool of applicants
we're not getting that pool um
in a diverse manner and so if we
if we had the doe submit that to all of
the usual suspects um
to uh to coin a phrase um
that would be a good idea then then it
would be the pool that the uh speaker
and the senate president would uh would
be able to select from and and get the
diversity that i think
we all are seeking
representative schultz has a question
thank you madam chair and thank you uh
sponsor for taking my question
um
i'm curious i've also have attended some
of the meetings and it's interesting the
topics that they picked seem to be
things that maybe they would agree upon
even if there is party diversity do we
do we know
[Music]
i'm um to think of the way to word this
i mean
is the assumption based on the topics or
is the
that they pick things that maybe they
should disagree on or is the assumption
that they agree
because they're all of say a similar
uh future party choice because
i think the topics they pick to work on
seem to be things that they
i'm not testifying i apologize
i'll let you answer my question i
apologize it's a good point you make um
i'm not sure if the tail is wagging the
dog or or the dog wagging the tail um
it is uh
there are subject matters certainly that
um that they have always been interested
in um
and um and so some of those some
it may be a self-fulfilling property as
you say um
but um but that would be something that
we would we would certainly want to
discuss and see if there's a a better
way to organize it may be something as
simple as uh you know the
the legislative
co-chairs maybe
they um select the bills that the youth
advisory council
evaluates i don't know i you know that's
just a possible solution as well
representative goalie has a question
thank you madam chair it's just a
question of the chair do we need to
do a roll call before we start this even
though it's a continuation and to make
sure nobody has any trouble getting on
i think you're right i i apologize for
having forgotten the uh
the statement and the roll call
um
so
after representing fellows has a
question and after that we will pause
for those technical technical issues and
then continue with the hearing
thank you thanks for the reminder
representative
thank you madam chair um representative
hill you've been talking about bills and
the legislative advisory council taking
positions on
bills and you're looking for a diversity
in that but is is that really the role
of the student advisory council because
when i read the statute
that's not what it says it it says it
talks about
their responsibility is to
identify issues that are important
to
to their
cohorts
and
and advise the legislature on these
issues and submit an annual report to me
that almost sounds more like the
functioning of a
study commission can you just comment on
your perception of exactly what they
should be doing
sure um thank you very much for your
question um so
i agree with you um if you're looking at
uh
at k colon one um that is exactly what
that says if you look on uh at k colon
three um which are the duties
um they talk about uh advising the
legislature president and speaker on
proposed or pending legislation
state budget expenditures and policy
matters of youth of concern to youth
advise the standing joint standing
committees of the legislature and the
legislative study committees commissions
on issues of concerning to youth
conduct an annual seminar
meet no fewer than four times conduct
public forums
so there's a number of other duties
other than what you're
you you may read in just the section one
okay so thank you it's quite diverse
what they're supposed to be doing thank
you absolutely yes
are there any other questions for
representative hale
okay seeing none we will take care of
some
housekeeping details
first this is a
meeting of the edna committee
as chair i find the due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coven 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
first one to executive order 20204
this public body is authorized to be
electronic
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
the house calendar for today an
executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporarian easily during this
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform the public has access
to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91k
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs at lege.state.mh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescued
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
and we will now take a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also state where there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to know
mr clerk
representative
present
representative bailey present in the
committee room
representative
um present home alone
and selling in for
representatives representatives
representative grazie is here and home
alone
here at home and my wife is in the other
room
representative
[Music]
in the uh committee room representative
mcguire president in the committee room
representative o'brien
a president um here in nashua alone
representative pierce
did you say you were alone
i am not necessarily alone because i'm
mobile today
for the most part i am yes
representative roy
here
representative
i am present at my home in pembroke
representative schultz
i am present in my residence in concord
and my husband will be in and out of the
room
here committee room uh representative
jacob
present
right outside all alone
coming in
oh okay great uh
representative
full house
excellent all right thank you all and
apologize for not doing it on time
uh the person only other person who
signed up to speak on this this bill has
not is not present as far as i can tell
is there anyone else who would like to
testify on house bill 457
madam chairs
hello
um i did sign up to testify my name is
elinka and i'm the youth co-chair of the
council i'm not sure whether my request
to testify i guess you did i didn't see
you listed apparently representative roy
promoted you before i caught you please
thank you please introduce yourself and
begin
thank you so much um terry mcguire and
all members of this committee
my name is alinka drondo and it has been
my honor and pleasure to serve on the
new hampshire legislative youth advisory
council for these past two years
this is the second year of my term and i
was elected as youth co-chair this year
by my peers
i am grateful to be part of such a
committed group of young people who do
bring a diversity of experiences to the
shared goal of representing youth
perspectives to the legislature
increasing civic engagement amongst
youth and taking concrete action on the
issues that we care about
last month i delivered personal
testimony on hv 457
which was written without the
consultation of any current members of
the new hampshire liac
i am now back testifying on behalf of
the council today
as a whole we support the passage of hb
in conjunction with amendment 2021 672
h
as introduced by representative joe
alexander our legislative co-chair
we collaborated extensively with
representative alexander to draft this
amendment so it is reflective of the
council's needs opinions and suggestions
the council supports the passage of this
bill together with the amendment for an
abundance of reasons
first of all amendment 672 ensures that
the council may and i quote
prepare and execute programs such as
public forums surrounding issues that
youth find important in new hampshire
this is a significant improvement to hp
as it empowers us to engage on all
issues that we identify as relevant to
young people rather than job growth
explicitly as originally mentioned in hb
the amended bill also tasks the council
with advising the legislature the
president of the senate and the speaker
of the house on proposed or pending
legislation state budget expenditures
and policy matters of concern to youth
as well as advising the joint standing
committees of the legislature
on issues of concern to youth
all of our members truly appreciate this
expansion of the council's functions and
we are eager to fulfill these
responsibilities
and i just want to give a bit of context
as to how we currently operate um
every year our liac members are tasked
with having conversations with other
young people in their communities
because all of us are cognizant that
being on the council is a privilege and
we are here not only to represent
ourselves but our communities of youth
um
so we have our conversations with
members of our school communities our
extracurriculars any sort of our larger
counties um
and our first meeting is always
dedicated to bringing forth our findings
and the issues that we have found that
resonate with youth where we live um
and
we compile a list at the beginning of
every year of all of the issues that
were brought forth not just by ourselves
as youth but as i said by our
communities at large
oftentimes the issues that i will bring
forward as a representative of
hillsborough county will be echoed over
and over
by
other members of the council from other
counties from other areas across the
political spectrum
and upon sharing our community's
priorities we then determine the ones
that have resonated most widely across
our council members
and through a vote we determine which
ones are in the majority and which will
garner our focus for the year
so this term the issues that
overwhelmingly stood out were healthcare
including mental health
education
voting rights substance abuse
environmental protection and gun control
we have organized into interest groups
surrounding these issues
and between our monthly meetings each
interest group identifies legislation
pertaining to their topic
and then they will bring it forth to the
entire council where we will discuss ask
questions debate and then vote
we then craft statements and deliver
testimony like i am today to convey the
youth perspective to the legislature
so
ultimately i appreciate how in amendment
these functions are explicitly mentioned
in the bill allowing us to continue our
work and setting this precedent for
future councils to be able to have their
voices heard in the legislature
another reason that we support this bill
if it passes together with the amendment
is that its wording enables us to
continue meeting virtually
which is likely to be appreciated even
post-pandemic
this not only improves the accessibility
of the council especially for those who
have not yet gained their driver's
licenses
but it allows for greater regional
diversity as distance will not be
prohibited for participation
and it had been in previous years when
we were meeting in a centralized
location in concord um given that for
instance members from the north country
would have to drive a very long distance
to attend our meetings
the amendment also stipulates that the
council may hold public forums if it
chooses
which is also greatly appreciated by our
members
we find that public forums are essential
to our operations of the council given
that they enable us to fulfill our
mission of ensuring youth civic
engagement
we are very happy to organize these and
last year we had been working on
planning five across the state before
covid19 prevented us from doing so
we use these events to hear from experts
on the topics that we identify that
youth care about
and spread the word about liax in a way
that resonates with young people
having it as an optional duty encourages
the tradition of forms to be maintained
by liak but it adds flexibility that is
appreciated given the current public
health situation
the amendment also ensures that council
members can represent a diverse
cross-section of new hampshire youth
including post-secondary youth who are
members of the workforce
this was originally lacking in hb 457 as
introduced
we believe it is an essential component
so that a true diversity of secondary
and post-secondary school types and
occupations are represented in the
legislation legislation
including youth who are members of the
workforce
we also appreciate that the amended bill
will create a youth outreach coordinator
position as one of our elected offices
for the past several years the youth
council members have opted to elect an
outreach coordinator in order to provide
updates to legislators through
newsletters as you may have received
in the past and conduct social media
outreach to promote youth civic
engagement
we also appreciate that with the
amendment incorporated hb 457 will go to
go into effect at the beginning of the
next lac term rather than 60 days after
its passage
so
i think um i will suspend my remarks on
behalf of the council right now and just
add some points on behalf of myself in
response to some of the things that
representative hill brought forward
um
i'd just like to mention that one of my
favorite aspects of the council is how i
know many of its members and have gotten
to know them outside of our council
meetings and we do represent a diversity
of political opinions across the
spectrum many of us supported vastly
different candidates in the past
election
and
what the council has taught me is that
it is possible for us to unite across
party lines
and to identify issues that resonate
more broadly and to understand that we
have this duty to represent not only
ourselves but our larger communities
and that's my favorite aspect about the
council we've been able to be very
productive in representing what youth as
a whole think in the communities that we
represent and to
forge friendships and also a great
relationship um like a working
relationship to be able to take action
on these issues that we identify
despite the fact that we may have
supported different candidates so our
parents may belong to different
political parties and i think that is
where lyac finds its strength um
and then also i would like to add that
in the amended version of uh hb 457 we
are
incorporating representative hill
suggestion to have the president of the
senate and the speaker of the house as
the appointing authorities
and i would like to mention that
the idea that the application process is
behind perhaps lack of diversity of
thought is not addressed in hb 457 as an
application process is still maintained
um
so
i i just wanted to address that because
i think
that's something that
you know is worth bringing up in terms
of how the bill and the amendment
function
um
and to go back to my testimony on behalf
of the council as a whole
our council really appreciated the
opportunity to take an active role in
drafting amendment 672.
we believe that the amendment adds
greater specificity to the bill
developing further on the council's
responsibilities and tasks while
empowering its members to continue with
active service to represent new
hampshire youth as is our mission
we are firm in our position that we only
support hb 457
if it is passed together with amendment
since that will make beneficial changes
that fulfill the council's needs
thank you and i would be more than happy
to answer any questions you might have
thank you i have a question
i was looking at the amendment and i
don't see
where it specifically authorizes remote
meetings could you find that for me
oh yes um
the wording enables remote meetings
given that let me split up
i believe it says that um
oops
i'm trying to pull it up
right now
the document is loading for me
okay yes if you could if you could get
back to us on where that is because it
doesn't appear to be
in the version either the original
amendment or the revised amendment
so i'm i'm concerned if that's necessary
it needs to be changed
right so what we um
we believe that the fact that it says
that we may meet no fewer than four
times per year um
is enabling us to meet virtually as well
since it does not specify that an
in-person location
is um mandated
which
we worked closely with to draft so that
it would provide options for future
meetings so we could eventually host
them in person or hybrid or online as
well
um
i don't think that's the standard
interpretation of the word meat but if
if you think it's necessary to include
hybrid or virtual or online options i
would tend to agree with you
all right thank you for the feedback
that might be something adding to the
amendment to elaborate
representative roy
thank you matt thank you for taking my
question um i i just have a few concerns
about adding the post-secondary um
proportion to it
isn't the the purpose
of the legislative advisory council
i said advisor council to get the youth
prior to them be able to actually hold
off themselves
people in post-secondary active
education can actually run from
representatives themselves
and you could that could be someone all
the way up to age 26 27 years old who's
in college influencing freshmen
in high school
how do you feel about that
that great gap
in purpose
to my knowledge um according to the
current statute uh surrounding the
council any one between the ages of 15
and 22 is able to serve
so we decided to maintain that to be
able to continue providing that
diversity of you know educational type
so we currently do have
high school students from all sorts of
different types of schools i personally
am educated at home
we have many public school private
school members um
and we also do have several college
students and members of the workforce
and this would be maintained in the bill
and um
our current council believes that that
is beneficial in representing a
diversity of opinions especially because
for instance our members of the
workforce will bring forth insights that
i as a high school student probably
would not yet have having not entered
the workforce myself um
so
we the council itself does not find that
to be a problem and um
wanted to make sure that that diversity
could be represented in the bill but um
yeah thank you for bringing forth that
point i hope that answers the question
thank you representative
i was trying to find my unmute thank you
madam chair
good morning ms drondo
i will tell the committee that i did
attend
as an observer
the meeting that they held yesterday
and was quite impressed
they had various members
assigned to do
research on some of these
issues that they were dealing with
they all seemed very well informed
i heard differences of opinions
expressed
during the meeting and
no the votes were not all unanimous
and i i just have a question for miss
rondo
i know part of
representative hill's testimony was
talking about
preparation for jobs and i'm just
curious i know you can't
speak perhaps for all the members but
for yourself
i doubt that that was your major major
motivation for participating can you
expand on that a little
yes thank you that's a very good
question um and i appreciate you coming
to join our meeting
um
i think my motivation for joining the
council was having an opportunity to
meet youth across the state um
who all you know were
united by the common goal of wanting to
participate in the government and
valuing public service and civic
engagement
and also just a personal
passion and desire to take action on
some issues that i see in my community
and that i would like to mobilize around
and i think that that stands true for
the majority of our members many of them
are really joining the council with the
desire to be able to
meet with legislators and
learn about the government's process um
and i think we were
as a council i can say we were rather
confused to see in
hb457 the fact that a responsibility of
the council would be to prepare and
execute programming on job growth
given that the council itself
has constantly you know been taking
action not only on job growth but on
learning about and representing and
um providing the youth perspective on
all issues that we bring forward as
important and identifying our
communities as i mentioned before so i
think that while job growth is a very
important issue that many of us
find ourselves concerned about and
wanting to understand and take action on
it should not be the only thing that the
council focuses on
but to that point about job growth i
think that's why it's very important to
be able to allow post-secondary youth
who are members of the workforce to be
part of the council and provide their
perspectives as our amendment would
allow because then we could eventually
take further action with more informed
and diverse perspectives on job growth
but of course included but not limited
to job growth
um
since as i said the goal is to represent
all of youth's perspectives on a
diversity of issues
thank you very much
are there any other questions represents
is there a list of your members anywhere
i don't believe we have a website but i
could send you the roster um i would
have to check with representative
alexander our legislative co-chair as to
how um
that's george
it was it's probably also on the house
website under statutory committees
yes representatives another question
i want to ask you about your outreach
maybe this is a better question for
representative hill because
something's very puzzling i've taught at
salem high school for 25 years
i've been on edna eight years nobody at
salem high school has ever heard of this
group i've never seen a physician paper
a white paper on any point of view
you've been invisible for me except
through notices in the calendar
so what are you doing to spread the word
of your organization
representative hill maybe
um i'm happy to answer the question for
my perspective but
i'm sure representative hill might have
additional insights um
we have these past two years appointed
an outreach coordinator with the goal of
increasing our outreach since we know
that that's something we definitely must
improve on
at this point our outreach consists of
compiling newsletters to legislators
which you may have received one i think
a couple of weeks ago with all of the
bills that we have taken action on um
this past year and crafted testimony on
and voted in favor or against um so we
have been doing that for several
newsletters
since last year and the beginning of
this year and we hope to continue that
and begin those on a monthly basis just
so legislators can be updated on
what the council is doing and we also do
have social media accounts on facebook
and instagram and twitter through which
we do post updates on our statements and
our positions
as well as our meeting dates and times
and our members and their biographies
and where they're from
so i definitely
encourage anyone who's interested to
take a look at our social media accounts
we definitely agree that increasing our
outreach is something that is essential
to the council which is why we
appreciate that amendment 4 the
amendment to hb 457 includes an outreach
coordinator position so one of our
members can actively take charge of
increasing our outreach
workers on fellows thank you madam chair
um
i can't i can't remember your name drunk
miss drondo uh can can i'm a little
concerned with the fact that there's 21
members of the council and the terms
that you serve are at least two years so
that's only 10 new people a year
that have an opportunity to participate
so i'm wondering if you could share how
the members that are on the council
came to be selected
and
if there's
kind of two questions and the other
question is in terms of outreach is
there any outreach to other students so
that they have some opportunity to
participate even if they're not
actually members of your council
yes definitely um i think to your first
point i am not the most knowledgeable
since as the youth co-chair i'm not in
charge of or involved in the application
process um
but uh i think that is sort of outlined
in the legislation itself and i know
that for instance to be on the council
myself i actually heard about it from
a fellow um member who mentioned that
she was on the council and she had
enjoyed it and encouraged me to apply so
the application was online and i
sent it to our email address and then i
believe it was
taken by representative porter who was
the legislative coach at the time and
forwarded to
the governor secretary of state senate
president and speaker of the house
to be evaluated
and then in terms of our outreach
we have been focusing on outreach to
other youth which is why we do put an
emphasis on our social media
which has allowed us to reach a lot of
youth in the state and let them know
about what we do
um
and then another aspect of our
programming that we really enjoy and
hope to continue doing our public forums
and in the past we have hosted these at
high schools and community centers
um
and they're essentially events on
different issues where we bring
regional experts on different issues and
we bring in state representatives and we
have student panels and these are
outreach events designed for youth to
attend so that they can learn more about
the council and also about the issues
that are relevant to youth
we were unable to host any last year
given the pandemic but we are hoping to
host some virtually this year and we
believe that
keeping those forums as the amendment
would do will allow us to continue our
outreach directly to youth with really
meaningful um
programming so that they can learn more
about the council and these different
issues
and be empowered to engage in new
hampshire politics
thank you representative broder has a
question
yes i actually have a statement because
one of my constituents is on this um
council
his name is brody parrott
and all i did was point him in the
direction of the
um
application because it's something that
he himself was very interested in and he
went through the whole process on his
own
so this is available to anyone who um
who applies
and um
it's at the recommendation of a friend
or a fellow representative so let's not
i want to recognize that we ourselves
have responsibility to introduce youth
to this process as well thank you
thank you
other questions representative roy
thank you um i i know you said that you
were a homeschooler yourself
could you give us a breakdown of the uh
of the demographics of the of the
committee with regard to
private school parochial school public
school if you could
i don't have access to the roster
immediately so i'm not entirely sure
about the numbers and the demographics
but i know that we do have public school
private school college home school
online school
and workforce representation at the
moment um
although i don't have um the clear
breakdown right in front of me but i can
look for that and send it along if you
would be interested
thank you very much for follow-up um
do you know off the top of your head if
you have anyone from any parochial
schools for example catholic high
schools or colleges
i am not entirely sure but i do not have
the roster in front of me so i i may
just be unaware i can send that along
thank you
questions
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 457 raise your
hand if you do
seeing none in that case i will close
the public hearing
and thank everyone who should appear
so we're
uh
representative roy has a motion
in this previous bill we just discussed
457.
[Music]
adam chairman representative was
breaking up i couldn't actually hear his
motion
i repeat it i move to retain hp457
is there a second
second
okay
by representative allegro plus some
squeaks from the zoom
i'm sorry could you please repeat with
them i'm sorry what was the motion i
didn't hear it the motion is to retain
house bill 457
as requested by book by the sponsors and
the committee
i mean the commission
is there would you wish to speak to your
motion representative roy
yes i would um just say that based on
the testimony from the sponsor
and from the
members of the commission member
there is quite a bit to look into work
on this
so i think that we ought to retain it
and give it to attention
personal allegro do you wish to speak
for a second briefly uh to honor the
request of the sponsors number one and
number two because it appears that we do
have some more information coming in
that we need to study thank you
representative shelton
i'm just going to support that motion
and i think
the fact that the advisory council is
now
involved in the process is a very good
thing i think having uh
vigorous debates as uh young people it's
a good thing for everybody and um i i'm
pleased to see how this is moving
forward
thank you anyone else wish to speak
right
seeing none the motion is to retain and
the clerk can call the role
representative roy
yes representative pearson
yes
president
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representing
zara
louise
representative schmidt
yes
representative
representative fellows
yes
[Music]
representative o'brien
yes all right that will be assigned to
subcommittee for work
and while we're voting
i'd like to recommend itl on house bill
which was
relative to out-of-state applicants for
occupational licensure and certification
seconded by roy
and i will speak to this
this bill
it was a repeat
it didn't incorporate any of the
recommendations that this committee made
to the author last year
and this
this session the oplc reviewed it and
found a number of issues
with
its its broad approach
and therefore
i think it's it is not ready for prime
time and i don't think it's
as written i don't think it's
necessarily a good base to work from so
i'm recommending ito
exactly not ready for my time please
representative roy
i i'm just the
state
does anyone else wish to speak on house
bill 405
yes i have my hand
representative yes you have your handout
thank you yes
i just would concur with
the chair's observation that
none of the recommendations that were
put forward from the last iteration of
this bill seemed to have been
incorporated
and
maybe if we kill it this time the lesson
will come through
anyone else who should speak on house
bill 405
okay in that case the motion is itl
and the clerk can call the role
representative roy yes represent
yes representative pearson
yes
representative jacob
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzaro
yes representative
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative gracie
yes representative
yes
representative o'brien
chair yes
does anyone object to consent
hearing none we'll put it on accept
representative
roy you have a motion
i do i would move
inexpedia to legislate on hb 84.
is there a second
second
all right would you like to speak to
your motion representative roy
i think that
you know i'm going to forget the last
name that was preferred but tony judge
um
was certainly a a brave human and um
recognition and i believe that the
governor is capable of making a
pronouncement on that
[Music]
thank you representative do you want to
speak to your second i concur with the
representative roy
does anyone else wish to speak on house
bill 84 representative schultz
i'm just going to say i'm going to vote
against that motion but i'm not going to
make a big deal out of it
fair enough
anyone else
representative scitec first and then you
thank you
uh this bill along with uh wentworth
cheswell
i'd like to see
them
retained
uh
to be talked about because
while my education was very brief in
this area i think i'm not so much
interested in naming a day as i am a
permanent building director to uh
honor somebody like wentworth cheswell
who was really quite a remarkable man
from the
little education i've gotten
i i'm not i just don't want to throw
these away i don't know what to do with
them but
maybe i can't for now but i'd let them
come back uh i certainly much more this
is
this woman was certainly courageous
but wentworth shedswill did a lot more
for our republic
and uh
i
this is just a
it's not a simple area as far as i'm
concerned i'd like to see something done
i don't know exactly what
yes thank you madam chair i was just
going to point out that
we did have an amendment i believe put
forward by
representative scitec on this bill
and was curious if he wanted to have
that considered
we have to deal with the itl before we
can consider any amendments
thank you i i just represented
i would certainly vigorously support my
amendment for reasons if we get there to
uh
but let's we'll wait for that
yes i would agree with representative
scitec that we should certainly not pass
this bill unamended
because we had the information that the
honoree preferred her married name to
her maiden name and didn't like the
nickname so
i think it would be embarrassing
for us to pass the bill on moments
but meanwhile we're discussing itl and
representative goldie wishes to say
something
thank you madam chair and
as i've said um putting
days into statute um naming days
i'm
against
but i i think this might need just a
little more
study and looking into uh as
representative scitec has said
so i would be in favor of retaining we
haven't heard anything from
the peace uh trade port on the airport
or a number of other things dealing with
this bill and i'm
leaning towards retaining
thank you
and groups and fellows
thank you madam chair i i just um
am reacting to what representative
scitec said about retaining and i think
and i think that it's important to
honor
um some of these people that we have
named bills about
but there may be a better way to do it
than just passing individual bills for
example i'm not saying i'm not trying to
put anything on the table but i just
think that there are other possibilities
that can be explored
so i would prefer retain so i'm going to
vote
no on the itl
represent right
i still i still move itl i i just
i think you could find uh we could find
bipartisan agreement on cash naming uh
he's uh for uh wentworth chaswell which
would be another issue altogether
that
as far as just taking this this name
off the calendar day i think that we
should just put that
put that to rest right now and then
we'll move on to something else
representative
well a couple things first that there's
such a thing as a friendly ipl i'm going
to call it that
but uh i'm going to say that
representative goalie sort of
embarrassed me the fact is
we really haven't talked
heard from keys and it's kind of nervy
to just name the building without
running it by them and having
letting them
uh
bless the thing i don't know why they
would object but the fact is it's
impolite and i think it's a wonderful
point for representatives
other uh comments
questions
all right in that case the motion is itl
by representative
thank you
um
realistically why does the new hampshire
state legislature have to be involved in
the naming of something that's in
portsmouth can't the city of portsmouth
just handle that why is why is this all
being thrusted upon the legislature
because it was included in a bill that
let's just say that we don't normally do
this but we can actually we do normally
do this
we get naming bills every year we named
a roundabout in uh
uh off 101 in the name of a local
activist the town was
the legislature the only body that's
required to do this can the city of
portsmouth not handle this on their own
i believe that the peace authority has
you know that's it's their building they
can call it what they want however if we
tell them to call it something different
they have to go along is i believe the
way it works
right representative schmidt has a
comment
thank you ma'am chair so
uh i've been unable to reach
represent county representative
steve fournier uh with regard to this
issue but of course uh peas is not the
property of the city of portsmouth
nor the city of newington it's property
of the state um and uh the the state
uh has
the control over the legislature
uh sorry as the board of
peace because it appoints most of the
members um
and so
it's it's
we've named bridges
for
uh deceased members of the armed
services and so forth and so on so
there's nothing more common for us to do
than
vote for the budget of course but uh but
another very common thing is to vote on
the naming of things that are state
property
thank you for the clarification on the
ownership of that representative schmidt
it is in fact state property there's no
question about it
anyone else
all right the motion is itl by
representative roy and the secretary
follow the role
representative roy
yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes mr representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lazzaro
yes
representative
yes representative gold
no
representative
with hopes for retention no
representative judy no
representative schmidt
no
representative schultz
representative fellows
no
representative from though
sorry representative gracie no
no
representative
reluctantly no with hopes of retention
representative o'brien
no i have the chair
i'm going to vote no so we can retain it
and in fact i will move to retain
second
thank you very much
by mcguire to retain
[Music]
and i would like to say that although i
don't want to
hold grant this person called whatever
her virtues a day
on the state statutes
i do think we can consider the naming of
the terminal at peace
and come up with a
name either her proper name or
someone else that might be more
appropriate for that terminal and i
think that's
our legitimate
one of our legitimate issues is what we
call that terminal this is the perfect
bill to consider
representative schmidt do you should
speak to your second
yes madam chair uh
i've already pointed out and it is known
to the committee that owner judge uh
haynes i believe was the last stains um
uh
was a slave of the
first president of the united states
uh and she
made not just a a dash for her freedom
uh and but she fought for it
uh the the former president
uh or justice column george washington
made numerous attempts
to have her
uh return to his ownership
uh so it was an ongoing battle uh you
know as i said the book
is held by the portsmouth library in
their rare books room uh that tells the
story of her struggle to
maintain her liberty
i think
there could scarcely be uh something
that would be more indicative of a
person's worth than their
uh than their successful struggle
against the most powerful man in the
united states
uh uh and uh so naming uh a terminal for
her
uh it could be uh
a symbol of
our respect
for another human being's desire to be
free this is the
the the underlying
premise of this country
freedom
let's at least take the time to
uh to to give it some due consideration
thank you
anyone else
represent like this
yes i mean i'll vote for retain the
reason i voted itl is i'm starting to
get a little concerned about the number
of uh
bills we're retaining if we're actually
gonna have time to do anything effective
um the alternative would be somebody
you know doing the research and coming
forward with a bill
for next year but i'll vote to retain
yes anyone else
all right scene none the motion is to
retain house bill 84
i'm ready the clerk can follow the rules
representative roy
yes
representative pearson
mr clerk i i was unable to uh
hear representative pearson's vote he
said no
thank you thank you representative
yes
representative
representative allegra no
representative bailey no
representative lanzara
yes
representative
representative gold
yes
representative short
that yeah yes right
yes representative judy
representative
yes
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes and the chairs yes
[Music]
15-4
fortunately we don't have to debate it
on the floor it doesn't go on account
uh yes
like to make a motion about to pass on
house bill
that's the uh
vendor's one
we have already passed an amendment to
218 yep
is there a second
second
so i'm sorry the the motion would be
that on to pass with amendment is that
correct the motion was already passed on
a previous day
the amendment yes
and
you would give us a number
representative like this
uh the bill um two one eight
all the amendments oh the amendment
sorry i'll have zero two five six
okay
that is correct
yeah thank you
that's my legacy
all right
the communication is a little bit
difficult this morning i did not hear
that last remark
the motion was by representative lekkis
seconded by representative allegro ought
to pass with amendment 0256 which you
have already passed
thank you madam chair you came so loud
and clear
madam chair yes
um looking back on my notes
we
actually voted on ought to pass with
amendment
back on the 26th
and there's no outcome
then we voted on itl
and there was no out
the votes were nine to nine right so we
are now going to have
since we there was intervening business
we can make a new motion about to pass
with the amendment
we don't have to reconsider either of
those
no if they if we had finished with the
ought to pass with amendment motion and
it failed then we would have to
reconsider
since it is
there was intervening business namely
the motion of itl
we can proceed with a new motion
um i'm still a little confused i i
thought with a thai vote
that that would be considered having
failed yes representative the motion of
ought to pass with the amendment failed
a subsequent motion of itl also failed
we can with there has been
things have elapsed time has elapsed
business has been done and now we make a
new motion that is on its passive
amendment
there's been no successful amen no
successful motion on this bill except
the adoption of the amendment
correct thank you
okay president would you like to speak
to your motion i would thank you um
from the testimony we heard
the uh you know for both the itinerant
vendors and the uh peddlers um this the
amendment combined the two
um the secretary of state's office is is
doing almost nothing i mean they're
collecting the fee and issuing the
license
but um they're really not doing any
checks on the people
you know who applied other than they did
apply
and
testimony was that they've never had to
make use of the bombs that are put up
at least in the memory of the assistant
secretary of state
and in his memory there's uh
never been any complaints um so
basically
in my view this bill is doing nothing
um the
municipalities and towns
have the ability to pass ordinances
related to this on their own
the other thing i mean there was concern
expressed about people that might be
going door to door to uh
either to maybe case houses to see if uh
you know no one's home so they might uh
uh at least my interpretation of what we
said so they might you know rob the
place
or commit a burglary and um
or they might be uh you know
going door to door to offer some
fraudulent product
and
um the issue there is i mean such people
are unlikely to uh i mean almost
certainly aren't going to get a license
anyway
and um
so i don't see it offering much
protection the only possibility is that
you know i suppose someone said the
police could check and see if they have
a license
but that doesn't really
um
you know they could and that you know
they could report them for that but i
think in most cases um
people that do this sort of thing are
taking advantage of maybe taking
advantage of people
and in most cases they're not going to
end up calling the police
and i really don't i see this offering
um
you know almost no benefit whatsoever
and for the legitimate people um doing
business who do get a license it's some
additional trouble and cost and i think
the people that are doing this kind of
work are kind of on the bottom end of
you know there may be exceptions but i
mean they're struggling to get by i
suspect in most cases and i don't see a
reason to put
even a relatively small burden on them
so that's why i uh
you know i'm going to be voting on to
pass with amendment on this thank you
sons of uh
allegra
um
i agree with everything that
representative lekka said
but what i'll do is reserve my own
reserve putting it into my own words to
come
only if it's necessary later
all right representative fellows
thank you i'm just uh i i don't have 218
right in front of me um it would take me
a minute or so to look for it but
i
the title is itinerant vendors so aren't
we talking about the people who set up
um a tent and sell things out of a tent
in a parking lot where this is not a
bill about going door-to-door
that was
that was 217
and the amendment that we adopted the
last time we discussed this bill
combines the two bills and repeals both
of those licenses
the amended title the amended title is
now repealing rsa 20 relative to hawkers
and peddlers and rsa 321 relative to
itinerant vendors
okay i'm i'm sorry i think i must have
lost that amendment
yes
it's not her
and it simply
deletes both rsas
and and
deletes the mention of them in the
powers of town section
anyone else wish to speak
represent
the thing that
i guess
the deal breakers i can't think of a
better word is when i heard that even if
the person applying for the license puts
down criminal background
the license is still issued
i guess i just wanted to say so
thank you representative schmidt
thank you madam chair again i'll
repeat my refresh my remarks from the
last time
uh we should definitely should not be
removing uh the state
statute with regard to hawkers and
peddlers
the committee had this a very vigorous
discussion on this about 10 years ago
[Music]
and the testimony from the towns
as i recall was all
uh in favor of having some sort of state
involvement uh so that uh
they're not
put at the mercy of people who are going
to come to a town
and then go to another town and another
town and another town that's what they
do
um and and to the degree that the state
has issue
issues or license it's not the money
they make that was misinterpreted the
last time they made the remark the the
aspect is not whether the state makes
any money at it the the the question is
whether the state loses any money at it
which they don't because the cost of the
license operation is covered by the
license
and for the state to have at least a
registry so that the town can call up
and find out whether they've complied
with the first step
of the statute which is to get a license
um and the fact that the towns can still
uh act against these people just means
that they everybody has to be on the
alert with no central uh uh collection
of information agency which the state
would be under the statute so leave it
alone it's doing no harm and it's doing
some good for sure
representative fellows
thank you now that i found the right
amendment um i'm opposed to this bill
because one i mean in addition to that
all the things other people have said
about you know people taking advantage
of
um
senior citizens and that sort of thing
that if people are going door to door in
a rural section of the state like where
i live
they they are not going to it's not
going to be feasible for them to try to
stop in every town and go to the town
clerk and get a license because the town
clerks aren't even open on all days and
if if they're really
you know
up and up
on the up and up then it would be easier
for them to just get a license with the
state and then they can go to any town
in in the state and and do their their
business so it even from a business
perspective this doesn't make any sense
to me thank you
first the license is meaningless but the
second question is from representative
fellows the can the town not insist on
its
own um
licensing in addition to whatever the
state license is yes you can and and
sometimes so so what
paul can still do it
and many towns choose not to
represent allegra
uh thank you i'm i'm
going to vote for the repeal uh in other
words i'm going to vote for 218. i have
uh three reasons first is that peddling
is a
quintessential
american act of commerce
and it seems that what we've done in
this and in so many other cases is we've
taken that liberty away and now we want
to sell it back with a license uh
something that we should all be at
liberty to do is to sell something to
somebody
number two is that uh
the reality is as representative lekker
said and i just want to emphasize it and
express it in my own terms
crooks do not register so
this law as it currently stands is moot
third
i don't know about other folks on this
committee but i've known a number of
people who work as peddlers
or hawkers whatever you want to call
them setting up sandwich stands at fairs
going door to door to try to sell their
wares
they're
working hard
to scratch out a living
and we're going to force them to be
licensed to do this now
here's the real crux of this for me
somewhere along the line and some of the
testimony or
comments i heard might not have even
been in this room
i heard someone say that if they saw
somebody driving down their street and
going door to door
they would be worried
then a
representative just a few moments ago
said
or expressed that going from town to
town
and door to door
that's what they
do
i think referring to uh
these people are expecting that they
are dishonest
because of the means that they a lot of
these people can't afford a storefront
or to pay a web designer so they can
sell their wares online they go
door-to-door they're scratching out a
living i think that referring to them as
we're expecting them to be uh
dishonest or criminal
is uh highly
prejudicial and that's why i'm in favor
of letting these people
make their living without
additional regulation
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i will be
voting against this motion um as i've
stated in
uh the previous
exact session we had on this
that these are
folks that are doing transient sales
moving from town to town and um
like we discussed that the by the time
one town catches on if they have an
ordinance that you shall get a license
it shall be registered these individuals
already in the next town i think it's
going to be difficult to track
where their movement is and
who they really are if we don't have a
state tracking and state licensing on
this um so for that reason i'll be
voting against and i don't think this
prohibits anyone
from selling their wares
whether they have to go through the city
or the town or to the state for
licensing
no one is denied the opportunity to do
that without delay with the license
thank you
thank you representative fellows
hey madam chair i would just like to say
that when i commented and said that they
go town to town in in door to door that
i did not say that they were dishonest
my comment was that it would be easier
for them to get one license from the
state
thank you for the clarification
representative fellows
does anyone else wish to speak on house
bill 218
okay the motion is ought to pass with
amendment 0256 made by representative
leckus
and the clerk i raised my hand madame
chair i agree thank you representative
schmidt you may speak thank you for for
speaking no no it's okay it's you got a
lot to do there
so uh
i i didn't say that's what i i also
spoke on this issue i didn't say that's
what they do
i said that's what they do
okay they go from town to town now it is
an old-fashioned existence but that
doesn't mean that nobody does it um and
i didn't
say that
uh that hawkers and peddlers are uh all
dishonest i i but certainly to the
degree that people go from door to door
in and from town to town uh is a
somewhat precarious existence um and uh
to the degree that and this is one of
the things that
that is a common phenomenon in towns uh
and that's at all so common in the
cities is that people have long
driveways um and uh and they they
many people like their privacy they
prize it that's one of the reasons they
live out in the towns uh one of the
reasons they live out in the towns is so
they can have more privacy they have
frequently have long driveways and their
houses are kind of out of sight
that's what they like and that's fine i
don't have a problem with that if i had
a big piece of property maybe i'd have
that arrangement too
so the point is that to the degree that
that
there may be some people
who uh will take advantage of a of an
opportunity um
you're you're a betting effectively uh
they're in a nefarious activities but
but to the degree that people want to be
in privacy some people put up a sign
says no trespassing or no peddlers and
so forth and so on uh
uh
it all goes to
respecting the people's desire for
privacy and not to be bothered
um but not everybody that feels that way
puts up a sign so we have a strat we
have a
scheme i'll call it not no negative
connotation to the to the term but we
have a concept in statute that's been
there for decades
it hasn't been doing any harm it's been
giving the state and the towns a little
bit of methodology and modality to
to try to keep people safe
and
this this desire to
clear the statutes of everything that
somebody conceives to be unnecessary
or out of touch with with modern day
realities
uh is no argument to do it when there's
clearly some benefit to it and it's been
there for years
no problem so let's leave it to do its
job
thank you representative schmidt is
there anyone else represent bailey
i i was interested by representative
lakers's remark that
it
they collect the fees and it
pays for the collecting of the fees but
but nothing ever happens like it's the
department of redundancy department
i i think we could live without this
thank you
issues
okay the motion is ought to pass with
amendment 256
and the clerk can call the rule
representative roy yes
yes
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzara
yes
representative
representative gold
no
sure
representative judy no
representative schmidt
no
representative schultz
representative
no representative grayson
no representative
no
representative o'brien
there's a chair
yes
i'm fine i'm an addict
all right did you say does anyone object
to consent yes i did already report it
all right and yes excuse me how can
there be even a discussion of consent
with a split vote of 10 to 9. it was
facetious
it's a joke
i'm sorry
representative schmidt are you going to
be writing the minority report
we will discuss that among us
all right so the minority recommends itl
and we don't know if there's going to be
a report
not at this time and i'll do the uh
all right thank you
i apologize for for not recognizing the
chairs uh you know joe attempted humor
is the phrase
that would be insulting to call it an
attempt at you
thank you representative
schmidt i appreciate it
all right
and i'm going to move itl on house bill
licensure of music therapists
is there a second
okay
representative site seconds
and i'm going to say that this is
another
repeat
we got it back we had it last year we
worked on it extensively
and this version does not include any of
the work that we did so i think that the
people that spent quite a lot of time
working on it are
have been disrespected
i'd also like to point out that the
office of professional licensure can't
tell if it's a regulatory board or a
advisory board so it's very badly
written
there's no rule writing authority
there's no discipline possibilities for
someone who is a
music therapist and misbehaves and there
are no penalties so
basically it's a way for somebody to
show to hank to hand
the office of professional licensure
their music therapist certification and
the check
and get a stamp that says now you can
get insurance reversal that's all it
does
and i don't
i don't appreciate that
uh
it's it's a sloppy bill i wouldn't want
to pass it
and i would also mention that every
single person who spoke in favor of this
was either a music therapist
or someone who was receiving music
therapy and wanted their insurance to
pay for it that's all it's cute it's not
a question of whether music therapy is
useful or desirable
it's simply who pays for it
and i don't like that
if i can remember my parliamentary
inquiry on this uh last year was this
licensing is designed to protect public
health and safety
and however meritorious this discipline
may be i cannot see a threat
worthy of legislation
of state interest
in a
danger to public health or safety from a
music therapist
i
[Music]
i was just uh attempting to make a bit
of a joke saying i assume this pi had an
if i know in it
it was properly formatted yes i do
i'm sure
does anyone else wish to speak on this
bill
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair i will just say
slightly disagree with my distinguished
uh colleague from the latin department
the um
it's not just health and safety but it
is to impose some standards in
professions
so that that the that the public
uh had should have some uh degree of
assurance that the practitioner has some
comp level of competence um and that
that's not to be sneezed at if the the
chairs characterization of the bill is
sloppy and uh and so forth may well be
the case uh
the people who offer the bill may not be
any more immune to the effects of the
pandemic than we are
so uh i will be voting against the
motion uh because i
think uh that the
practitioners have made a decent
argument even if the
if the form of the bill is uh
uh is defective in this instance
thank you representative bailey and
that's my job
the uh the part that concerned me was
that the audio therapists testified that
they thought this encroached on their
turf
that and that would speak to your
point that it was poorly written that
the boundaries between the two fields
were not clearly delineated
thank you representative
yeah uh
representative schmidt if i may address
you on this point there's actually some
maybe a little crack of some
slight area of agreement that i think we
can forge but i want i've resisted
saying this about the last bill let me
just throw it in fast i've never seen us
so divided on on the nothing bill i mean
so
our common sense tells you you don't see
people swarming the streets and
defrauding
that's enough
uh representative schmidt there was
someone somewhere in this proceeding
this session and i don't have the memory
to know it where one of the disciplines
had strong professional standards but
not licensing do you remember who that
was
and music therapists have both
professional standards they are
certified by their professional
organization there is a certification
and there are there is a professional
organization that sets standards and
people can meet those standards
uh
and call themselves a certified uh
music therapist
that sounds reasonable to me
could i um make a suggestion
representative yes i'm so sorry i didn't
raise my hand
apologies um
since there seems to be so
since we
since we looked at this book could you
speak a little louder i can't understand
you
okay
i think i didn't have my volume online
much better much better sorry
um since um
we have such concerns over the bill
about the way it's written and the fact
that it didn't include some of the
um
language
i'm wondering if we could get through
this vote and i'm going to vote no in
hopes that we'll retain the bill
because we do have a language that has
passed this committee before
and we could use that language to
improve it thank you
i'm sorry i'll ask i'll ask i'll add i
don't think that this is going to be a
lot of work to fix
thank you
but you worked on it last year
and
the work was completely ignored
representative schultz
oh i think representative schmidt had
his hand up before mine
yes but he's already spoken three times
so true okay thank you madam chair sorry
about that i think that
obviously this is a philosophical
difference in our committee and that's
you know something that happens i just
for the record since we've talked about
the sort of components we would like
to see in such legislation
i think it would be a good idea to
include
music therapists art therapists and any
other type of therapist that work
especially with patients
after trauma and the specialized type of
care
that the patients who do well with these
types of therapies receive and include
it with the
overall
statutes around therapists in general
and i think that
um
i think that given the seriousness of
which
this committee has taken mental health
issues in the past and this session i
think that it would be something that
would benefit us all
to look at these modalities as another
couple tools in the toolbox
um
to assist people
that have
resistance for whatever reason to talk
therapy to have these other options
available to be covered by their health
insurance is certainly something that
would be good i wish we didn't even have
to legislate that i wish it was already
happening but i think given how
complicated ptsd
[Music]
childhood trauma etc is i think that we
should look at all these modalities that
are available and unlicensed
to
retain this bill
and look at creating better statutes
around these types of alternative
therapies that are helpful to many
people that's just my two cents
and why i will vote against the motion
to itl so that we can retain it
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
um so to my distinguished colleague from
salem uh
we are in in this day and age uh in so
many ways uh captives uh
as well as beneficiaries to some degree
of
the insurance sector uh and so
this situation is such that
that things that are uh you know put
forward as therap
as therapies
uh very often are covered by insurance
or not
uh and therefore um to the degree that
someone is is
doesn't have a license no matter how
qualified and how much they're
acknowledged by their by their by their
uh professional boards
or oversight agencies uh to be competent
and and worthy of a license to the
degree that the state does not provide
them a license opportunity the insurance
companies won't pay for the coverage so
that that's just a reality that that
they have to deal with and the fact of
acknowledgement by their peers uh does
not entitle them to coverage by
insurance
that's something that this committee of
which the democratic members are all
experienced with except representative
brian whereas on the
on the republican side we have a bunch
of people for whom this is all brand new
um and and uh not all obviously the
experience members are not in that
category but the new members are not
experienced and so for them it's a new
world uh and so
you see the it's not just a
philosophical difference but also
what we've dealt with excuse me
representative schmidt thank you for
your
discussion about the nature of the
committee would you care to comment
about the bill
we know you're voting
my only concern one of my major concerns
is that we
we're saying you know we need to pass
this so that insurance covers it
passing this would not guarantee
insurance coverage that's just wonderful
the insurance company can still decide
they're not going to cover it this
doesn't mandate coverage all it does is
provide for a license so
i don't
i don't think we should be in the
business of picking and choosing
things based on hopefully the
insurance company to cover something
represent side check i want to ask the
question out loud
point blank
do we
accept as a criterion for licensing only
for sure not maybe only but the fact
that that will provide insurance
coverage
public health public safety and
insurance coverage should that be a new
criterion can you just accept that yes
and i would like to mention to
representative schultz
that her concern about therapy that the
music therapists explicitly said they
are not mental health therapists
they are
more aligned with the
speech language pathologists they are
primarily working in the schools
they're not like the art therapists who
were
mental health therapists with this the
specialist
representative schultz
thank you and madam chair did have a
hand up before you speak i wasn't
necessarily going to respond to what you
said i did want to say though to the
point about insurance i think
that is just an auxiliary component of
recognizing a profession that's
legitimate
and should have standards in licensing
or certification i think that while it's
not formally on the list
uh given how insane our health insurance
uh is about coverage i think it is
something unfortunately we have to
consider that legitimizing professions
through licensing
and certification at the state level is
a really important thing
for the tools in the toolbox i think
that is an important auxiliary component
of it but
uh i don't know
i
i'll leave it at
that
anyone else
okay
the motion is itl
on house bill 209 and the clerk can call
the rule
representative roy yes
yes representative pearson
yes
representative
yes representative
no
representative judy
schmidt
no
representative
representative fellows
no
representative
representative murder
no
representative o'brien
and the chair yes
all right
motion promotion is adopted 10 to 9 and
we'll put it on the regular calendar is
anyone going to write a minority report
yes
okay representative grota
your recommendation is
do you wish to pass it or
to retain well i would like to retain it
excuse me madam sheriff's chair
that cleared away a lot of the bills we
haven't uh
we've had on our stacks for a while
does anyone else have another motion
we might get one more lunch
yes we have a we do have a public
hearing at one o'clock on a brand new
bill we haven't seen before that's house
bill 141.
seeing none in that case i think we will
recess and uh
take a break oh
or am i moving too fast
okay we will resume at one o'clock with
a hearing on house bill 141.
thank you
i was considering 575 but i think it
takes
[Music]
oh thank you
we will see you all
thank you
foreign
it is one o'clock
and i'm opening the public hearing on
house bill 141
and i call crime sponsored
representative
good afternoon can everyone hear me
yes
great thank you
um yes
thank you chairman mcguire and members
of the um
executive committee um i am uh
representative rosemary rung for the
record i represent hillsborough district
21 which is the town of merrimack
i come before you to introduce house
bill 141
which would
establish a registry for firefighting
foams in new hampshire
that contain pfas
and the reason this bill is so important
is that we've seen in new hampshire
several communities whose drinking water
has been contaminated by pfas chemicals
it could be from a landfill it could be
from in merrimack we have uh industrial
contamination
and it's it doesn't take a lot of pfas
for it to have serious health impacts so
understanding where pfas is in our state
is important as many
residents derive their drinking water
from groundwater
and
we know that as pfas leeches into the
ground from the use of fire fighting
foams
that contain pfas
it contaminates the groundwater
so i'd like to ask the committee to
consider this bill it ought to pass i'd
actu i'd like now to actually have
former representative uh the honorable
nancy murphy speak on this bill
it was first
introduced and passed uh the committee
in-house last year
but was ended up in covid purgatory
so if i could ask nancy murphy chairman
if you could indulge me to allow her to
speak more in more detail and answer any
questions the committee has
fine miss murphy
[Music]
thank you
good afternoon madam chair and honorable
committee members
my name is nancy murphy i'm a merrimack
resident who had the honor of serving my
community in the house as a rep last
term
while there um i filed uh hb 150 1569
and it was a bill that would require des
to create and maintain a public uh
publicly accessible a triple f
registry uh that was my appreciation and
thanks to representative wrong and the
bill's co-sponsors reappears today as hb
141.
um i i um
sort of just briefly for people that
don't know what a triple f is um it
stands for aqueous film forming foam
it's a class b fluorinated legacy foam
and it has pfas in it it works by
cooling and smothering a fire so it
can't reignite
it's often used to fight flammable
liquid fires at military installations
and airports
when a triple f is utilized to put out
fires the spray contents wind up on the
ground
the foam which contains pfas
seeps out into the soil and binds to the
soil particles and stays there
every time it rains or water reaches the
soil pfast compounds are forced into the
groundwater potentially contaminating
the drinking water
chair can i just
ask that the representatives adult
former representative
indulgence we've got some cross talk yes
that i'm hearing
yeah i hear it too i'm not i don't know
if whoever's has the background noise
including the dog please mute yourself
actually everyone should mute yourself
unless you're speaking
it sounds as though there's a television
or radio playing in the background
yes thank you appears to have been muted
by whatever background noise it was
please continue miss murphy oh thank you
um i i asked i i provided my testimony
here in terms of questions um are pfes
really
all that big of a deal and why is a
triple f concern
like many other states across the nation
new hampshire is dealing with the
environmental and public health impacts
of pfas of our air water and soil
they take decades to break down in
nature and they bio accumulate in the
human body
they've turned up in water supplies and
in every county in new hampshire
many public and private drinking water
supplies are contaminated which based
upon current research emerging science
and new enforceable drinking water
standards would deem them unsafe to
drink we need safe drinking water to
live
though we're all exposed to toxins on a
daily basis some new hampshire citizens
are at a greater risk of associated
health impacts from pfas exposure
simply due to proximity to a pollution
or contamination source
or occupational exposures like dod
military sites such as pease air force
base
and that experienced by firefighters
using a triple f
their body's uh ability to detoxify
chemicals can make a difference and the
bioaccumulation and other properties of
these environmental toxins
unborn babies and young children
exposed
can be exposed in utero because it
crosses the placenta and during
breastfeeding or bottle feeding uh with
formula mixed with pfas contaminated
water um the baby's blood levels go up
um infants and young children have the
highest levels of pfas in their blood
around age 12 it seems to go down
because the children grow um and it's
sort of pfas gets dispersed in their
body but by adulthood
pfas exposed males have higher levels
than females as they don't shed pfas
through menstruation or
breastfeeding health impacts um are
certainly concerning uh associated with
pfas exposure the center for disease
control and prevention national center
for environmental health and agency for
toxic substances and disease registry
have declared that human exposure to
pfas is a public health concern exposure
to elevated levels of pfas and products
containing pfas like firefighting foam
or drinking water that's been
contaminated by it increases of several
forms of cancer thyroid disease
hormone disruption increased cholesterol
autoimmune disorders
reduced vaccine efficacy including
covalent vaccine
reduces birth weight and head
circumferences in babies
and uh they're looking to see right now
there's growing evidence that it also
affects growth learning and behavior of
infants and older children
um it's really important that this
a triple f registry be created
so that des can have this record
a triple f foams are a major source of
pfes contamination and environmental
exposure
this registry will create a publicly
accessible data collection tool that
will enable des to track the presence of
and thus citizen exposure to class b
firefighting foam associated pfest
across the state
when des knows where the p fast from the
a triple f is impacting groundwater or
is likely to do so it can take action to
assist communities in the protection of
that drinking water in public health
i see this bill as sort of the first and
necessary step in a process that could
eventually coordinate with the work of
dhhs
it would make it possible to plot an
overlay on gis mapping uh class b
firefighting foam-associated pfas
exposure
and potential health impact data from
dhhs
it would be a valuable data collection
tool that would have great potential to
assist both agencies
it would bring us one step closer to
providing data that can lead to answers
that are being asked now by des dhhs and
at least two statutory committee
commissions that i can think of relative
to pfas drinking water contamination and
health impacts
des um supported uh this bill in 2020
um and uh they
their their suggestion they felt that it
would identify where foams would have
been released it would help the agency
prioritize investigative and clean up
resources and ensure clean safe drinking
water is provided to new hampshire
residents
also the fact that it would be public
would help inform the public about this
topic of high interest
with limited resources in time why
should we do this
new hampshire is ranked number one in
the nation for pediatric cancer breast
cancer bladder cancer and esophageal
cancer
it's known to be associated with cancer
and other concerning health issues
and cancer we know is an environmentally
triggered chronic disease
the vast majority of cancers are
preventable
although it's a simple registry may not
seem particularly important nor that it
should be considered a priority for for
this committee when access to and the
availability of safe drinking water
water that we need to to nurture and
sustain life
and public health protections from toxic
chemicals that have such concerning
associated health
outcomes and long-term environmental
impacts around the line that simple
registry tool becomes far more valuable
i would ask that the committee please
consider the value of this bill to the
many thousands of granite staters whose
drinking water and health is at risk
from pfas and a triple f and allow 141
the opportunity to move forward and be
voted on by the full house
effective and safe methods for putting
out oil fires are
critical to protecting health and
property however pfas containing
firefighting foam has created a toxic
legacy across the state and poses an
occupational hazard to firefighters who
train with it and use it likewise when
class b foam seeps into groundwater
and contaminates drinking water citizens
across the state are unknowingly being
exposed exposed to these very dangerous
chemicals that are known to be linked to
such concerning health outcomes policy
makers must take action to protect
drinking water public healthy in the
environment i ask that you vote otp on
hb 141 so the des will have a tool that
it needs to help protect new hampshire's
vital natural resources and the public
health of granite staters thank you for
your time
thank you miss murphy are there any
questions from the committee
representative
would you uh send your testimony by
email
absolutely surely thank you
representative fellows
thank you madam chair um
representative
the honorable
i can't remember your name nancy
nancy yeah
do you have any
idea about how often this occurs in the
state like how many times a year this
foam is discharged
oh thank you for your question
um actually
that part of the that's part of the
problem is um there's not been a lot of
documentation and and record keeping um
it depends upon the department some
departments you have used it more than
others certain areas like the fire the
training academy would use it all the
time uh for training purposes
many fire departments don't use it at
all so the um the issue is that um
there's a lot of of this um
firefighting foam stored in different
places all over the state and i know uh
when i wrote this bill senator tom
sherman had written a senate bill 257
which um
was adopted and in 2019 and part of his
bill required that um des survey
municipalities um about what they have
in stock and that actually was just i
just saw a december um
uh
report from that from ges and i i mean
there are
depending upon the there's only about 50
compliance and i think in uh 58 percent
of compliance responded to the survey
and about 32 percent of those people
that responded had no a triple f
um
there were reports of 8 375 gallons
either in storage or on apparatus were
identified and that will be need to be
disposed of and then another five
additional responding firefighting
entities listed an additional six
thousand four hundred and twenty one
gallons of a triple f in new hampshire
um the the part is is it's it's this
storage it's um the usage and
looking the important part is to look
back and to see where it was was
discharged because
it may not be used now but a prior spill
could have impacted the groundwater in
certain areas so that's the concern it's
it's actually not going to
most places are not using it they're
using fluorine-free
foam so it's not it's it's really much
less of an active problem now but the
damage has been done so that's really
what we're looking at is to see um where
it is and and uh you know what what uh
groundwater needs to be be tested
so follow up please
um thank you
okay so
if it's
if it's not
your biggest or big concern seems to be
what has already happened
but this bill
doesn't
only requires them
to talk about what they have now and
going forward correct no
no thank you for the question no this
actually requires that um the fire
departments or it wasn't just fire
departments because there it is uh this
almost stored in places other than fire
departments um and i try to look at the
the um the language
uh
where
it says on on in section c and d
of all locations where this film is or
has been stored captured collected
managed or disposed of
and indeed
any known dates and locations where the
phone has been discharged in the past
correct yes thank you
okay
uh representative o'brien
thank you uh madam chairwoman i i do
have a couple questions
uh is there
when fire departments mostly that i'm
concerned with providing information of
the historical data
that they have used these such as uh
class uh b type of fires
or other incidents where
their intention was to extinguish the
fire for the uh the public good does
anything in this
uh bill
hold harmless to municipalities
who
at the time that was the only
extinguishing agent that had the class b
capabilities
or
also too is more than just class b type
of fires
a triple f was also using uh alcohol and
ketones which is why
that particular phone was
so dramatic and so universally used but
anything in this bill because this
information will be provided by the
municipalities honed them within harm of
any type of future suits
oh thank you for your question um no it
doesn't speak to any liability the
purpose was not for liability it was
really to to have a tool to investigate
where
it is or where it has been so that the
groundwater can be examined and drinking
water can be protected so without the
the information in a central place for
des they don't know
it would it would clue them into where
they might need to because it's going to
be a big task we know
department of defense sites we know you
know fire um fire departments airports
we we know it's everywhere um and it
will help prioritize work for des
because um i i know um
this pfest thing has sort of become a
nightmare for our state and um this is
one of the the uh
the uh big contributors of of be fast so
i it does not address
um that wasn't the intent
uh to to do for liability or anything
like that i mean i think it's i think
our whole state is covered so it's not
it would be very hard for anybody to
i would think sue anybody or or or
really
a hold liability when it's our whole
our whole federal government our
you know our our states our towns our
municipalities i
it's a it's a huge issue so it's really
a
a a
registry for purposes of determining
safety of the water more than it is and
that has any it has nothing to do with
with life
representative you had a question well
follow up madam chair follow up
representative o'brien thank you madam
chair uh it will be very brief uh i see
in line 13 section d it says within 120
days
of the effective date you want the
municipalities to give you
of any of their known dates
in some of our larger departments where
they probably have somewhere in the
avenue of
30 000 reports that they uh that they
respond to annually
many of it was done in the past prior to
the use of computers do you feel the 120
days
that you mentioned this bill is enough
time
for municipalities to provide that
information
i would certainly be uh
think that an amendment if if the time
frame was really the issue i think i
think it's
to the the time frame was set with the
goal of compliance um and to to have an
end date and to a start date and i i'm
sure for especially larger departments
um that would be challenging i i know
des is um it's been
any interactions that i've seen with
them around pfes has been very um
amenable to to time frames but certainly
if the committee felt that that time
frame was was a problem you know i i
would certainly understand a need to
to change that
very good thank you representative thank
you thank you oh thank you
representative
thank you madam chair ms murphy welcome
to edna
i want to um ask you i sit on the um
seacoast drinking water
safe drinking water commission
and des does participate in that
are there any
other
groups other than d e and s d e s that
might be interested in this information
that could be added to this bill
i'm not sure that i understand your
question uh
that other other commissions you mean or
yeah
um well i sit on senate bill 85 which is
the environmentally triggered chronic
disease with uh senator sherman and also
the hb 737 which is the um
pfas
commission related to bedford merrimack
litchfield and uh londonderry probably
and
um
very much a lot of the work that we're
doing on all these commissions and i
would imagine it's similar in in your
commission is um
trying to get a handle on this problem
and we and the problem is we all know it
exists we talk about it we have we have
concerned citizens really concerned
about their health um and there's no
data collection there's no way to to
give people a sense of where do we need
to prioritize um assistance from des or
dhhs so i know in the other commissions
we're looking at
um targeting particular health impacts
you know that from like the c8 study um
to start there um i know d uh dhhs has a
new um computer program that's that's
coming in i think that will be helpful
um and i i think like this registry
would be helpful as as much to dhhs as
it would to uh to des so i i am i think
it'll be valuable any data that we could
get gives us uh a foundation and i think
that's what we're struggling on in a lot
of commissions is that we just don't
have the data we're not collecting it so
this was a tool that
the es fell would be would be helpful to
start
follow-up medium chair
so i just want to make sure that um
other
groups we would have as access to this
data through d yes is that what you're
saying
oh thank you for the question yes it
would be a public it would be it would
des would be would keep it and it would
be publicly available yes for for
whatever needs that that other
commissions would have shore okay thank
you very much thank you representative
uh thank you madam chair um look at the
bill i noticed that the phrase class b
firefighting foam is used in five places
however
in only one of those five does it say
does it add you know class b
firefighting foam
to which pfast chemicals have been
intentionally added
and my question is are there class b
firefighting phones that do not include
uh pfas and if so
isn't this going to require reporting of
things that really aren't a concern
in some cases
to my knowledge class b firefighting
foams
um have pfest
and actually a um we have a i know a
person that will be testifying
after me is is a pretty good expert on
firefighting um equipment and foams and
such and certainly can probably answer
these questions but to my note to my
knowledge um
class b
uh firefighting foams repel carbon
they're fluorinated uh so and they have
pfas
so um i
actually think that was an olf um
creative
language thing i'm not i'm not sure that
follow-up yeah it's just i noticed it
because i was wondering why it was in
one place and not all the places and i'm
also i guess the expert maybe can answer
but wondering whether there might not be
developed if there aren't already a
class b firefighting phone that would
not happen fast thank you yes thank you
not to my knowledge yes thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh and looking at
and i just want to follow up on
representative o'brien's take on this
because uh being a retired firefighter
it says that
the reports shall include
and this is shell location date time and
volume of the discharge
um is it like i said as a retired
firefighter we didn't keep records of
the amount we dispersed in a given
location
so i'm just wondering on when this is a
shall report
how you
think this information will be collected
if there is no record of it
thank you for your question um i i i
think that's an excellent point and i
think that's going to be an expectation
i you know i don't think fire i have
many family members who are firefighters
and um in discussions with them i know
historically things were not necessarily
kept and there was not a uh in
anticipation that there would be a need
to do to to do so
i think the point will be more to
provide the information that's available
and i think unders i think gs is going
to certainly understand that
not everybody is going to have all the
information that there will be things
that
can't be answered but i think it's a um
a best
best
um
recollection it's it would be the you
know what what whatever um records are
available i think that's the point i i
don't think any expectation of of you
know 30 years ago that people are i
think it's that's probably not possible
but whatever information there is to be
had
should be collected
follow follow up
so
should child be changed to make
or if available
for a language
thank you every question um
you know i i think that
if avail i i don't know i i don't know
that if available
i don't know i'm i'm wondering if
there's a way to to you know maybe a
men's language that says something to
the effect that uh
you know as rec per records or or per
perv you know whatever's on site right
for record keeping that's available to
to um
the departments um something that so
it's so it's clear that it's just not
that there's an acknowledgement of the
expectation of the request to report but
that the reporting is not complete
due to lack of of available information
or or this the um specific information
okay because you understand where i'm
going with this with the shell we're
asking requiring them to provide
something that they may not have built
right and right thank you i i would
agree
i don't think anybody can can can can uh
respond to something that they don't
they don't have access to and i think
that the intent is to obtain the
information that is available
yes ms murphy yeah i have a question
sure thank you
it seems to me that you're asking every
fire department in the state
to research 30 odd years of records to
get this information
how are you expecting them to pay for it
i thank you for your question um i um
you know
the departments would would within
however they manage staffing i i expect
that it's something that would would
would probably
require if maybe for a larger department
uh additional staffing support
um for initially i don't think it would
be anything given given what we know in
terms of the use that it's not going to
be used now
this is this is sort of a catch-up
time that i don't think ongoing it would
be a a um
an ongoing expectation of that would
require additional staffing um so i i
you know i recognize that it would be
um
it would require some some uh you know
some some
manpower for a period of time and you
know i think that would be up to the
departments i i don't certainly don't
have a sense of of the cost
for that
thank you
representative pearson
good afternoon
ma'am i'm um
you've kind of you've kind of hit the
harness nest here because i also have 25
years in the fire service myself
and i am a
fire service historian by hobby and i'm
a published author of
the historical firefighting book
um one of the things
that's
massively concerning about this bill
and i and i don't know if you you can
try to answer this um
realistically what you're asking for i'm
going to just tell you right now is
going to be virtually impossible
okay because you're not talking about 30
years of records you're talking about 60
years of records records that were never
ever kept or maintained in reference to
the information that you're looking for
please understand that those of us in
the fire service have have a very
legitimate concern over pfas and and as
you stated it's an emerging
it's an emerging thing when it comes to
cancer not only in the fire service but
but other places
you you stated that
it would be pretty much everywhere in
new hampshire well my question to you is
this if it's really kind of everywhere
in new hampshire and you're looking to
conduct testing
for specific reasons
why bother with the fire service why
bother with
the places
the training areas that we know it's a
given
if you're really looking for this why
not just conduct the tests that you're
going to conduct anyway and cut
cut this requirement totally out of it
oh thank you for your question and thank
you for your fire service um i i think
it's it it's pretty clear to all of us
that there is no way that we're going to
be able to get information from 30 years
ago or 60 years ago i'm sure it doesn't
exist i'm sure maybe information from 10
years ago might not even exist
the point was to get as much information
as was as was available
um
in terms of you know the the um the
testing we certainly when i when i say
it's everywhere we know it will we can
expect it in the places that you would
agree you know for the fire departments
and airports and those kinds of things
but
i mean des we know staffing for des is
limited resources there are limited as
well
and this would be a tool that would
enable them to
target the areas that may impact
um that are most in need of
drinking water protection or impact the
the largest uh population
um and you know that would be for them i
think it would be cool for them to use
um to to in their discretion to figure
out how they were going to target um you
know the different areas of the state uh
and and yeah i know the tool that uh the
um the survey that came out of uh senate
bill 257 was a help i think it gave a
little bit of a
a window into you know where
most of the majority of the the um the
foam is stored
but there's still so much to learn and i
think
you know i i i agree it's a it's a huge
task i i i
totally agree and i understand i i
fighting in merrimack here for the last
five years about
you know six wells so i can imagine
we're talking six wells with a lot of
contamination not with when you have
multiple places with multiple uses and
records that aren't great um
but we have to start somewhere and um i
think that that the um
this registry allows
you know um the state to start someplace
so thank you great question
i'm sure
keep in mind if you're asking for
municipalities
cities and towns
to do the dig
you you've just now given us an unfunded
mandate
okay because
you know you're looking at
the cities in nashua manchester
concord anybody that's got highways
airports you're talking about a very big
dig here
to to try to
even begin to look at this um
you know would it wouldn't it make more
sense to just draw a line here and say
okay
you know starting whatever january july
we're going to attract this moving
forward
and not try to
have the state ultimately the state
would have to fund
this look back across new hampshire and
wouldn't it just make sense to just
draw a line and start forward
oh thank you for your question i i agree
we have to start someplace and it would
be great if we could just start now the
problem is is this the impact
is where we've already the impact
already exists so so
so as much as i'd you know it would be a
nice clean and easy to say okay from
this point on but really from this point
on i can't imagine that other than
storage that there really would be any
use of of
the um
of a triple s like so i i i get that it
won't be
as as much
labor intensive or or there would be as
much involved in working foe and i and i
absolutely see the the value of that
however the problem is is is we're
trying to find out where have we where
what areas are already impacted areas
that we might not have that you know
might not have been directly next to an
airport there might be you know the
groundwater plumes and and things might
have just impacted areas that i know
here in merrimack that you know we would
not have been expected so
you know i
certainly understand
the desire to move forward i think you
know that's certainly a starting place
but um in order to
to
address the the contamination that is so
widespread we need to know where it
already is
here one more time
one more
miss murphy you're aware that there are
federal exemptions for certain
classifications when it comes to the
current use of this foam
this this is not something that is
completely stopped
so
i would hope that at least from that
point
you would be admittable to to
considering the fact that it's it is not
all gone away
and that doing a look from a line
forward
does have some value
well thank you for your question
absolutely it's always value and and you
know anything we know any data that we
have is valuable
um you know but i from you know my
understanding and i'm certainly not
um an expert on all of the regulations
but i i do know that there were some
changes and and that at from
2020 on that um
the uh
the use was the the um class b with uh
with pfas were not going to be used as
they have in the past that there were
non-fluorine alternatives
um so it was my understanding that that
was going to be
more of a um
the intent was to try to to sort of
limit the pfest exposure in the
environment
thank you mr ms murphy are there any
other questions for her
all right seeing none
i like to call uh
miss cotter
just unmute yourself
thank you and thank you for the
opportunity today
and i'm here in strong support house
house bill 141 for a variety of reasons
and elevating firefighter pfas exposure
is the wheelhouse of the advocacy my
husband and i um perform on a regular
basis
i'm diane carter
advocate and the wife of lieutenant paul
potter
from worcester massachusetts we now
reside in rindge new hampshire
new hampshire's own history with 3m the
one-time manufacturer of class b a
triple f
is notably not in favor of new hampshire
residents as 3m fights new hampshire for
its precautions and intentions
and its ability to protect its own
citizens in order to maintain their
control of the scope of the pfas problem
in our state
new hampshire is a leader in firefighter
pfas exposure initiatives and has the
strongest delegation of congressionals
that we've ever had the pleasure to work
with
when it comes to firefighters and pfas
used in their a triple f and in the most
highly fluorinated textiles seen by
science that is their turnout gear
the long overdue need to track and
register a toxic a triple f outweighs in
any potential opposition to the aspect
of the job of a firefighter
these are toxic exposures and no
different than any other chemical
exposure that must be reported as part
of the daily work by officers of the
departments that serve their communities
as the firefighter pfas exposure
experience grows one of the areas that
will benefit the citizens of new
hampshire is to log these exposures this
is done on a daily basis all over the
country when responding to an incident
and there are numerous free apps and as
advocates for this issue we can't stress
strongly enough how important it is that
firefighters protect themselves and
their families by logging their
exposures
the same goes from our municipalities
who are paying the cost of firefighters
stricken with cancers that are known to
be affiliated with the pfas chemicals
in our work we speak with firefighters
who must try to recall their own a
triple f use that they file as they file
for claims for compensation
and are saddled with trying to recall
what incident they used class b foam at
going back decades in their careers as
their cancers are now prevalent in their
bodies
if you have no records to show of
exposures to these carcinogens you may
not have the ability to protect the
citizens who may wish to claim damages
from deniers with endless amounts of
money in their coffers who scoff at the
thought that their chemicals are harmful
a triple f manufacturers have a long
history of awarding perks and incentives
in the form of gifts trips and dinners
to firefighters in an effort to keep
them close this has led to a false sense
of protection within the fire service
this is magnified by the fact that the
makers of class b phone belong to the
firefighting film coalition who provides
junk science to the fire service for
them to swallow excuse me ms ms cotter
could you please confine your testimony
to this bill we're not debating what the
evils of pfas
we're debating whether we should create
a registry
yes new hampshire des was first in the
nation in 2017 to advise firefighters to
test the well water in their firehouses
and has written strong language that
showcases the concern new hampshire has
for its firefighters
we see no reason for new hampshire des
to not continue as a leader in the role
of initiating this a triple f registry
for its bravest and its citizens who are
living in fear of unknown toxic
exposures in a day and age when
electronic data is collected sent and
stored in milliseconds we express our
gratitude to the representatives who
have drafted this bill
thank you
thank you are there questions for ms
carter
seeing none thank you very much
i'd like to call mr mike wimpsap from
ves
yes good afternoon madam chair uh for
the record my name is mike winsat
service director of the waste management
division for the new hampshire
department of environmental services
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to testify
on house bill 141 today
des does support this bill
and especially the intent of trying to
provide additional reporting so that we
have a better understanding of where
pfas containing foams may have been
either stored managed or disposed of or
used
we do have some concerns regarding uh
two two items on the bill the first is a
kind of a technical one and i think uh
uh representative goalie may have gone
to this with his questioning and that is
that we have um
the bill currently would require des to
go through rule making to provide the
forms and the and the structure for this
reporting by fire departments
and um then it also requires that the
reporting begin 120 days after the
effective date of the bill
and we're a little concerned that that
may not provide enough time
for the agency to develop the forms go
through the formal rulemaking process
advertise that to the folks who would be
reporting and then give them time to do
the reporting that's necessary so we
might suggest an amendment that might
extend that time out to 180 days or
whatever the committee might feel is
appropriate um
and and these the second issue is one
you know it's unfortunately one that
comes up with a lot of bills where we
where we support the intent
but uh we did provide a fiscal note
worksheet on this bill when it was sent
to us for when a request was sent by lba
and uh we did indicate that would
probably take on the order of about an
additional half of a full-time
equivalent position to it to to
structure
set up and
administer this program and we do note
that the bill doesn't make any
appropriation for
for that for for that kind of personnel
so we just want to register that concern
uh but beyond that again we we think a
public registry will help inform the
public this is a topic of very high
interest
uh we do have a number of examples where
the use or release of pfas containing
class b foams have impacted drinking
water in our communities and so we think
that this will help advance our efforts
to ensure that everybody has safe clean
drinking water and with that i'll be
happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions from
from the committee for mr williamson
representative just have one on the
website i know that you're an expert in
this but is it uh
did i hear that the uh while this is
meritorious
that
new firms have been developed where this
problem will be like lead paint and
eventually go away
thank you for the question represent
representative scitec actually um i'm
not sure exactly where things are at i
have had conversations with industry
folks over the last couple of years i
know they are working hard to develop a
class b foam
that is as effective
and there are some phase outs for the
use of class b foams
this is a very specialized foam that is
intended to be used for flammable liquid
fires and so of course the hazards
associated with those fires are very
very high not just from a fire but an
explosion that can occur as a result of
vapors coming off of the of the heated
uh flammable liquid and so uh you know
these are required at airports
and they are still used
where a
flammable liquid is is a concern at a
fire so
i'm not aware that my understanding the
last time i spoke with industry
representatives is that they are working
on this but they have not yet developed
a class b foam that is pfas free
that works as effectively as these uh
class b forms now it's important to
understand that the class b foams that
are in use now
do have pfas although they do not
contain they've been reformulated so
that the pfas compounds that they
contain
do not include some of the
more troublesome
pfas compounds that we're concerned
about so
pfos for example which is for
fluoroctane sulfonate which is a primary
component of these early what we call
legacy foams um that that that that as a
component of these foams has been phased
out so
if you will there's still pfas
containing foams we still have concerned
about the con the contents of the foams
but they are not as troublesome as say a
foam that was used 10 or 15 years ago
thank you
representative pearson
thank you manager
so the
des is estimated that the if i heard you
write half person staff
for the entire state of new hampshire
for
all of the municipalities that have used
this in it in the city of manchester
alone at least 5 000 locations that can
that could probably be argued or this
might have happened either in user and
training how on earth did you come up
with
the number of half a person
[Music]
thanks for the question representative
pearson um and i do want to emphasize we
don't have any half persons working at
dds but we often uh
we calculate calculate the amount of
time
that someone will have to work on
something um in fractions because
obviously a particular assignment
doesn't necessarily take an entire
position it's full time when we look at
this it will clearly be very front
loaded with work in terms of developing
the reporting system
getting that system through the rule
making process in the appropriate forms
and then
doing any uh you know perhaps
i t department to develop a system for
managing database for managing that
information
and then collecting the information that
will come in and so in the very
beginning it might well be more than
that but as we were trying to be
reasonable as we calculated out over
time
after those initial reports come in our
expectation would be that the intensity
and frequency of reporting would be a
lot less um so you know it's it's always
an inexact science trying to calculate
these things but we our best estimates
were that an equivalent of a half of a
position would be required to
stand up implement and then uh over time
manage this program
hold on manager
follow
so the up
that was made was based on the fact that
the municipalities will be expending
uh manpower and time to conduct these
surveys and not the des is that correct
certainly the information that is
required for those municipalities to
report it would be their job to to to
compile that information um to go to
your earlier question if i may
you know it's we have a lot of
requirements that sometimes ask for
information that just simply isn't
available and so if a as long as the
municipality made a good faith effort to
collect what information they had if
their reporting was not complete respect
to volumes or specific dates but they
provided the information they had
available i i think we would not see
that as a compliance issue we would
obviously be we would understand that
you know just because you write down a
requirement
for something that happened in the past
you can't necessarily expect the party
to have all of that information
yes and representative pearson there is
also no money
in that estimate for
the effort the towns the cities probably
would expend researching their records
that's correct
representative schmidt you have a
question
thank you madam chair so just to inject
uh a a a
potentially interesting fact
into the discussion uh i'm sure madam
chair you'll recall
and some of the senior members of the
committee will recall that roughly
three to four years ago we had a bill
with regard to firefighting foams
uh and so my question for mr wimsat is
whether
he recalls or he of his own knowledge
whether uh he participated in uh the
committee uh deliberations we had a
subcommittee uh and we examined this
whole complex of
the existing firefighting foams and and
what
aspects of
improving them removing the more toxic
and dangerous chemicals from them was
and so forth uh so
i'm just injecting that because mr
wimsat may have been involved in in that
in that process and that information
would be helpful to to the committee
with regard to this bill
thank you representative schmidt yes i
have participated um in testifying on
other bills and also on sub committees
that have worked on issues related to
this firefighting question and as uh
ms murphy indicated earlier we have
issued a report based on the the we work
very closely with the fire marshal's
office to reach out to
uh the firefighting companies in the in
the state to get information about their
stocks of pfas foams because we were
working on a program for for taking back
those legacy foams the older foams that
i mentioned that have higher
concentrations of more concerning pfas
compounds so we have made some progress
on that and we've also worked on a
number of sites where drinking water has
been impacted by the use of these foams
or the disposal of these foams so we're
learning more each day but we we still
have a lot more to learn
right i think that whatever was produced
with regard to that particular bill and
those stu and that study committee uh
report would be useful in in this topic
in any case
thank you representative fellows thank
you madam chair um mr wim said do you
know if any other states collect this
type of information
thank you representative fellows that's
a good question i i don't know
specifically any states that have
actually you know established laws for
the collection of this information i
know that a number of other states are
very aware of this problem and have been
working on many fronts to collect
information about how and where
not just class b firefighting foams but
other
materials that contain pfas have been
used and disposed of because
you know unfortunately as we've learned
more about this over the last five years
or so
fast contamination exists in a lot of
places and it's impacted a number of
both public and private drinking water
systems
are there any other questions for mr
wilmset
seeing none thank you for your testimony
i'm sure
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 141
raise your hand if you do
miss cotter
hi there i just wanted to say um that in
2008 minnesota did do an extensive
survey it's called the delta project and
i i did send it along along with my
written testimony
that you folks should have
and it really gives a great
review of the questions that were asked
to the fire services and their responses
of what they knew it might be something
that
that mike may want to take a look at for
new hampshire des as well
um
and also in i also included it as well
in my written testimony was the state of
michigan that also did a survey um and i
think they worked with their new
hampshire ge i'm sorry they're michigan
des in regards to uh surveying their
fire uh fire services so you can see
their response as well they actually
went on record to um put all 1400 fire
stations on their
potential pfas contamination sites so
but there's some great material in there
if you want folks want to take a look at
that
questions
[Music]
thank you very much
and anyone else
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
call it to the committee's attention as
well that our former committee member
former representative mark prue a former
firefighter as well
it was on the committee and was involved
in the bill that i referenced in my
earlier remarks
and he's somebody that the committee
might want to contact with regard to
his expertise on the subject because
i believe he's engaged in some
training
activities currently
and he might well have information with
regard to
to this topic
thank you
there
further testifying
[Music]
all right well um
while we're here does anyone have a
motion on this bill
[Music]
yes madam chair
yes i was
i was wondering if you had a motion
on house bill 141 mm-hmm
i i
will move
in expedia at the legislature
i'll second
well
um i'm chair if i may is
representative schumann i thought had a
known do you have an amendment on this
yes that's what i was going to say
if we kill this bill
uh can we
proceed with
the hearing on the non-germain amendment
next monday
we would
well actually you're right we should
probably not actually vote itl but i
think we should discuss it from that
standpoint
all right thank you then we will recess
before the vote
send goalie your comments
i i believe
that this
is an
unworkable um
solution i mean working for
city of manchester and
like representative o'brien said being
from nashua uh knowing the number of
calls we do a year and going back and
searching and researching records over
numerous years um is going to be at an
expense and
i think finding all of these locations
and recording them is going to be um
almost impossible
i'm surprised that some of the local
departments aren't here to talk about
that
because i think it will be
time consuming
and probably not even
being able to get it done i mean i could
see going from here on out going forward
but backtracking i don't think
uh is a reality so that's why i go along
with this
that's what i seconded it because i
believe it's a
uh downshifting to municipalities of the
of the difficulty of tracking
decades of use and trying to report it
in 120 days
and with no funding for the
municipalities
scitec yeah uh
i don't know
to whom this question maybe to the
sponsor i'm
representative
you're there so i'm not really asking
you
but what i'm thinking about the business
end of this is the drinking water supply
you build a house or you're checking the
municipal
water or
my the condo association i'm in in
londonderry
and they've got to lower
what difference does it make what's in
the ground it's what you're coming out
of your pipe and what you have to do to
treat your water to get it down to
the size like whatever
i'm not sure
you know going forward sounds not a bad
idea i suppose but
jeff i don't mean to be looking at you
um
i'm trying to put you on the spot i'm
trying to figure out
it doesn't matter
does it matter i have to purify my water
it doesn't matter what the survey says
or what was there it might affect me as
a builder whether i wanted to drill a
well there or not i'm talking too much
my concern is what good does it actually
do
that's it
representative pearson
thank you
madam chair um
as i as i stated earlier you know fire
service history is is a substantial
hobby of mine and i probably
knowing that knowing the players that
circle in that world in new hampshire
i'm going to tell you that probably
without exception i i have more
historical fire service documents than
just about anybody
my numbers for the city of manchester
alone are above 10 000. so
and i'm going to tell you that what is
being asked here is not possible it's
just not possible so i appreciate the
intent i appreciate the concern i i
certainly share the concerns of
of the member of the public whose
husband is a retired worcester
lieutenant and you know this is an issue
that the fire service does truly care
about
but we're not we're not debating that
we're debating house bill 141 and 141 i
i just you know sometimes i look at this
and go okay maybe is there a way this
could be tweaked to make it workable or
and i gotta tell you i've been racking
my brain about it and it just isn't it's
just not there
it in and i appreciate i'm sure what you
said as far as the downshifting of costs
it's
clearly that that's the avenue to which
they think this is going going to work
so
you know between between the downshift
costs and the impossibility
of of any fire department coming up with
the the information they're looking for
i don't see any other option but itl
um a few things one is um
the section statute that this repeals
and reenacts
already requires reporting the use of
the firefighting phone with pfas going
forward so that's already in statute
um i just did a little poking around and
a comment from representative pearson
there
there are
class b firefighting foams that
do not contain pfast they may not work
quite as well i'm sure they'll be
ongoing development
and at some point i imagine
you know
firefighting foam without p with pfas
won't be used but this bill would
require ongoing reporting of the use of
any class b firefighting foam
and uh well maybe that could be fixed
given the other concerns i think we need
to itl
representative harassing
yes madam chairperson um having been a
town planner for 20 years
i have some experience in
particularly locating developments but i
think that
excuse me
this is maybe something you want to
retain because
there was a discussion about just
dropping in a well and you're concerned
about not what's in the ground but what
comes out of your tap and of course
that's important but what comes out of
the ground and what's on the ground in
the ground
it can be very important when you locate
a development or locate homes you don't
want to actually build start developing
an area that may have some contaminants
on it this would help identify areas
that you could maybe clean up prior to
the development of a project at least
you know what your costs are going to be
before you start investing
a lot of work in the development of the
project i would hate to see a developer
go in
and want to do a site where there may
have been some fire testing 10 years
previously i certainly understand the
problem of the record-keeping and the
data that's out there but if it's at all
possible i think des did say this during
the
discussion was that they understand that
there's some places the information is
just not going to be available another
thing i have as well a concern that i
would have as well is that when you have
business or industries that are located
in an area and there is a contamination
that occurs or is found in that area
they may originally point the finger at
that industry or that business even
though they may not have nothing to do
with
somebody may say well there may have
been an illegal dumping of pfas if you
can show that there's a disbursement of
fire retardants at that time that were
pfas
then they could say it's not us it was a
test of the fire department so don't put
the liability on the business and this
would be another way to prove that
the business could use to defend itself
against an accusation that they were
contaminating the ground
and i think that i think it would be
better for the community to retain it
rather than to itl it so that you can
take a look at it and look at these
things and maybe put them exemptions in
there uh that would
cover
the problems that you would have with
eric gathering all the information we
should at least try
thank you
representative o'brien
ah thank you madam chair first i would
like to answer rob
i think it was representative lakers uh
but being on a
the fire department for 35 years having
worked at the nashua airport uh airport
fire certified
uh yeah we did use an awful lot of foam
uh
this particular foam that you're talking
about yes there are other protein based
foams that you can use on class b
flammable liquid fires that aren't as
harmful some of them the old ones used
to be made out of fish cuts they stunk
like hell but they did the trick
the thing is with this one in particular
is
again it's still in use as far as i know
it's
the hazards materials that fire
departments have to deal with today it's
today's modern society that is inviting
more type of products into their lives
that
where used to be natural type of
products so therefore what this
particular foam does
it could be used on just gasoline type
fires the answer is yes
but
ketones and acetones
alcohol in particular those products are
miscable and water and because of
miscobol and water this particular foam
works well in trying to put a film over
it and that's how it extinguishes it
also could be used in lower
concentrations to put on a a brush fire
so it does have multi-purpose but
getting to this
i originally was going to support
representative goalie's uh
itl but then it was mentioned uh perhaps
retaining the bill
and this is a very serious subject it's
opening up the door to something uh that
else is happening i don't know if you
know it but if you when you wear your
firefighter gear the same stuff that the
firefighters wear and fighting the fires
is made out of the same
uh products that we're talking about
here so just by putting on your coat and
your bunker pants you are exposed
but the thing is this is a situation
that does have in some communities uh
something pertained
uh i would wouldn't mind giving it uh
because of the needs of those
communities of giving them the crack to
look at it but there's a lot of changes
there will be a lot of work the 180 20
days
of notification you know that's going to
be have to be reworked and
make sure that municipalities aren't
going to be uh held harmless
and trying to come up with ideas so
i'll
i would be open to retaining this
only because the subject matter it is
something
uh being on the fire department we have
hazards materials teams we are concerned
with the environment
and if one of the products we are using
is causing some you know harm although
not maliciously
you know it's one of the agents we use
to help the public and extinguishing the
fires
maybe it might be worth behoovers
to retain it
take a good look at it and if the
recommendation from the committee that
retained it is to itl
then let's go for it but uh
it's something that is uh
worthy i think of us to take a look at
thank you madam chair
senator schmidt
thank you madam chair well uh first of
all uh it's clearly a 28-inch a 28a
issue representative pearson also
already likely referred to that earlier
uh but there's no question that this uh
bill is
not viable not workable and it's since
it's a very strong 28a issue with no
funding provided in the bill it's just
not workable so
but to the degree that we had some
mention earlier of
of an amendment
that could use the bill as a vehicle we
can study
this issue which is worthy of
consideration by the committee with
especially with our expertise with all
the firefighters
and for former municipal people on the
committee
we could study anything we want to we
don't have to have a bill but the bill
could serve as a viable vehicle for
this amendment i have no idea what the
amendment is but
apparently it's non-tremaine by one
remark i heard earlier so
that might be the route we want to go we
don't have to retain the bill in order
to study the issue
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair yes that that
basically is the point i was going to
make
uh if the committee agrees with my
non-jermaine amendment and
the amendment i'm hoping to put forward
has nothing to do with the subject
matter of this bill and
by virtue of replacing it with that
amendment
this particular bill would not be shown
as inexpedient to legislate
therefore a bill with similar
[Music]
tenants in it could come forward next
year
with no problem
and i hope that the sponsors are still
listening i would urge them to go
forward with that idea
and making some of the corrections that
were suggested here today
thank you
representative
my representative gracie if i might
address you for a second your town is a
lot kinder than ours
the our town would not pay for this map
they would tell them they're not
interested in saving developers money
they tell you the developer i built some
houses in salem and i decided i want to
sleep at night so i got out of the game
uh go go to rockian county conservation
district
get your soils tested but don't bother
us
just saying
ah
it's nice that we have local control
representative pearson
thank you i want to i want to jump on
something that uh representative schmidt
said
in reference to to the look back that we
did when we had when representative prue
was on this committee we did in fact
have a committee that looked at
this issue two years ago
and
looking back at the at the time the film
industry had brought some uh
some quote unquote technical experts to
our committee to try to shuck and jive
uh
edna at that time and and
we we kind of i think i think we beat
him down pretty hard i mean mark and i
were kind of brutal on those guys
you know but
but look honestly you know let's let's
not get lost in the weeds here as far as
you know yes
absolutely the fire service those of us
that have been in the fire service
really do have a have a concern over
over the gear and over the pfast that's
involved in all that
no question but again focusing back on
the fact that we're looking at house
bill 141 it which doesn't talk about
gear which doesn't talk about really
anything in relationship to the people
that have used this this is really just
about
trying to take a deep dive into
ground water contamination and i think
that can handle a very different way
um that involves very different angles
in
and just
this this right we looked at this two
years ago i mean the subcommittee the
subcommittee did some good work two
years ago so i think putting this back
into another subcommittee
to to do what we did two years ago
is going to probably produce the same
result so i mean if that's
if that's really what you want
thank you representative fellows
thank you madam chair um my my thought
is that um
retaining it would be a good idea
because
if we could just make it
not retro not reporting
events in the past but just going
forward that that would not be a huge
burden on the towns to report that and i
think it's important
for
not just groundwater issues but also for
the firefighters because it would also
be a record of their exposure also
yes except the current law already
requires reporting going forward
so we don't need to build
this is already there
okay i'll i'll look at that
existing statue
okay represent goalie
thank you madam chair and that's one of
the points i was just going to bring up
leading into
i would
ask that the
committee go and read
what this bill is looking to replace rsa
154 colon 8b because i pulled it up and
brings back some memory of when we did
pass this bill um
a few years back
and
that it does
require beginning january 1st 2020 no
person local government or state
agencies shall discharge or otherwise
use for training or testing purposes
class b firefighting foam which pfest
chemicals has been intentionally added
however testing
shall be done at regulated facilities
that are contained in treated disposals
done properly
um so we've already said that
they cannot be used um we've also
put in big uh there was a
des department shall survey
municipalities throughout the state
on the quantity stock and legacy forms
and determine the cost of instituting a
take back program
and beginning on july 1 2021 the
department shall institute a take back
program on these farms for the purpose
of safe and contained disposal
and then finally madam chair in in this
uh rsa is anytime a class b
and specifically to what you just spoke
to
anytime a class b firefighting foam to
which pfast chemicals has been
intentionally added is discharged
municipality making the discharge shall
notify the department of environmental
services within 48 hours of such
discharge
i think
this bill is doing everything this rsa
already does everything we're talking
about that we're looking to retain so i
don't believe there is a reason to
retain this because
um it is all being documented now here
on going forward
um so with that i
urge the committee not to retain it i
think the work's been done previously
and if you go look at the rsa uh you
will see that and thank you
thank you
representative allegro i just had a
procedural question of the chair please
um since we have a motion on the floor
are we allowed to
before we deal with that consider
amendments and other motions or
since it's an itl motion we cannot
explicitly consider our amendments you
have to have an ought to pass
recommendation to consider amendments
however my intention is to let us
debate this until it seems like we've
reached a conclusion
and then on next monday we are scheduled
to hear that amendment and after that we
can
uh
withdraw this motion
or and move on to pass with the
amendment or we can
uh
go ahead with the itl if we don't like
that
i understand thank you all right
no that's where we should go that's the
way we should do it carol
right where we will not take a vote
today but we should
finish the debate and uh
come to make up our minds
representative schultz do you still have
a question or comment
representative goalie answered it and
didn't even know it
good job
representative lekkas
uh
my question's already been asked
excellent we're gonna answer your
psychic uh i have a question to the
chair am i allowed to vote
yes sir
representative goalie frequently votes
correctly
you are however allowed to vote
the same way as him as he does for a
different reason
representative schmidt and then phillips
no no i i i already said my piece you we
should do what you suggested
uh and the the motion can be withdrawn
at the appropriate moment we can
look at this amendment whatever the heck
it is
then
thank you madam chair i'm just wondering
if we can ask mr wimsett um about
that
this section of the rsa we looked at
about
um that says effective i think january
2020 that municipalities should have
been reporting this
and if he's keeping a database of that
he's still with us yes he is all right
mr wimsat we will uh
we do want to ask that question
he's still here
yes uh
good afternoon madam chair sorry there's
a little delay there while i was uh
promoted to be a speaker again
um i i did hear the question and yes we
are collecting that information
um and uh i don't think we've gotten an
awful lot of reports but we certainly i
i think i believe we have received some
reports i'm aware of a few circumstances
where some class b foam was used um
sometimes we we have some direct
knowledge of that because our emergency
response folks who are on call 24 7
provide a lot of support to the fire
service when
um there are uh say for example a
petroleum truck that rules over or
something we often get called for the
environmental piece of that we provide
direct support to the fire service so
we're often
in the know when that kind of
circumstance has occurred and uh so i do
believe we have some information about
that yes
so follow up
yes just um so does that mean that
you're going to keep track of that
information so three years from now
somebody wanted to see that anybody from
the public who wanted to see that would
have access to that information
right so so anytime we get involved in a
response or receive a report it becomes
part of our records and those are public
records that would be available
well
i guess just to clarify
is it going to be in some kind of log or
would that all of those incidents be
kind of like in a spreadsheet something
like that
i think right now probably the answer is
the latter it's it's very likely in a
spreadsheet and but said that also if we
receive a report about an incident
it goes into our um
uh database of sites in a place that's
had a release where we've done some
received information and if you're
familiar with our one stop system where
you can go online and search in the
community for for information it would
likely be available there as well but
the short answer is yes we very likely
have it in the spreadsheet
okay thank you
goalie
thank you madam chair
like may a question of mr wimsat while
he's still here with us
please uh mr website i'm looking um and
it's supposed to be um
taking a survey of municipalities on the
legacy phones and the socks they have
and then it says
according to the statue beginning july
1st
of this year
you'll start instituting a take back
program
are you folks uh how is that going so
far and uh are you in
uh a place to start that on july 1st
sure so so we will be reporting on that
um
early on we were doing pretty well
because we had identified actually
a small source of funding through an
unrelated enforcement action that we
were working on
and a facility that could take these
legacy foams and treat them
unfortunately that that facility was in
new york state
and for a variety of reasons there have
been questions that's been called into
question whether that facility can
safely
treat those materials
and at least temporarily it is no longer
able to accept foams for destruction
so as a result there really isn't a good
uh option for disposal right now
and so we are trying to sort out where
we're going to go on that so we will
certainly report on that by the deadline
but i'm i'm sorry to say we're not going
to have
a take-back program set up and ready and
operational because we don't have
regionally or even really nationally
there are no good
solutions for where these materials can
be taken and disposed of
okay thank you
anyone else who wishes to speak on house
bill 141
no we're going to recess the meeting
and it could be
we could be changed
after next monday
yes next monday we are going to hear our
uh
two second committee bills
anyway we have a hearing and the
non-jermaine amendment on monday
and uh
and i expect we will probably
exact or try to
the few remaining bills we have we have
a leftover
representative
thank you madam chair um
being someone who loves horses and
does not care to beat a dead one
um i would bring up the subject of
our vote on house bill 208
i did consult with the clerk during our
lunch break
and he confirmed that we technically
should have
reconsidered
our previous vote on ought to pass as
amended
and
yes and in the future if it ever comes
up again i will do so i i
remembered a different section of masons
and i thought they could be renewed but
[Music]
i believe what you were citing uh does
apply on the house floor but not in
committee or something like that but i
appreciate that
i just wanted to be sure that going
forward the process would be correct
yes
[Music]
representative
if you love forces the only ones to beat
are dead ones
i agree
but i don't even i wouldn't even want to
be edwin
does anyone else have any uh issues or
concerns
in that case we will uh
oh
i represent goalie you asked about
getting someone from fiscal
to talk to us
and reply
about the emergency orders
yes
i think that's who it was
i just got a call that was not
that was i told representative weiler to
call it 215
and my phone did not vibrate so
he's willing to explain how fiscal works
and what what
hello is this kind of
look could you join this system
calendar
[Music]
to explain how fiscal works and relative
to emergency workers so
that
he's currently chair of fiscal and has
been on it uh
many times
should that be on monday next that he
will talk to us now as soon as you get
joined to the zoo oh now okay thank you
that was that was a question that came
up and
i don't believe any of us has had
actually served on fiscal so
it's unlike say
what was the question
how the
emer how whether fiscal could deal with
emergency orders
he's just heard from information
assuming this is the amendment to 417.
or any the other emergency bills we
we were concerned about oversight and
fiscal is definitely one of the places
that oversight would make sense
representative elect as my concern was
whether we should send it to governor
and council or governor and with the
oversight of the fiscal committee
so that's where i just want to hear
where fiscal stood in versus the council
approving expenditures and
appropriations actually there is a uh
statute which i don't remember the the
number of hand uh representative mcguire
pointed it out
that um
says
any expenditures over some amount that
had to go
to governor and council also had to go
to fiscal so i think this existing
statute made it happen
it's my understanding
at the moment you can because it's not
governor of council that was why
my amendment suggested
it's i think
i think it was rsa 1413a
part six let me take a moment
yeah fourteen is legislative officers
and proceedings and fiscal
fourteen
thirty
dash a is the fiscal committee
and that's where its responsibilities
yeah 14 colon 30-a roman 6 says any
non-state funds in excess of a hundred
and thousand
including refunds of expenditures
federal aid local funds gifts requests
grants and funds from any other
non-state sources
which under state law require the
approval of governor and council for
acceptance and expenditure
may be
accepted and expended by the proper
persons or agencies in the state
government only with the prior approval
of the fiscal committee of the general
court
so by adding governor and council to
governor and council i guess it uh
invokes
that bit of statute
has the government needed to wait other
statutes already
well that's
that's a good question and that's my
question is if we just by putting
governor council does it revert back to
that rsa or not because this is in 21p
colon 43 emergency statute
so i'm going to need to reference that
statute when we do this to make sure
representative weiler may be able to
help us on that
as soon as he gets here we'll have to
ask him
because that's really uh in the weeds
that's a good question
yeah
madam chair while we're waiting i'm
sorry if i missed this but i saw before
that there was an hb 533 regarding the
lottery commission on it was listed
previously for today
not today that's for next monday
we're hearing for
433 the lottery commission and
187 i think it is the emergency powers
of hhs
thank you sorry about that those are our
two second committee bills and we're
hearing them on monday
perfect thank you
i have an amendment on 187 just a fair
warning to everybody
thank you
i believe it should have been i think it
was distributed i filed it last week
yes i've seen it
look it looked pretty uh
housekeeping i'm afraid
madam chair did you speak to
representative wyler yes i did
that's right
i'm looking at the calendar
for monday the 15th
and it's saying we're hearing a
non-german amendment to 533 you should
also say the other two
related to pfas
yeah this morning
uh those two bills you mentioned madam
chair were actually listed for today on
one part of the
website calendar and then it changed
midday
well they were intended to be done next
week i mean i would have liked to have
done them today but i couldn't get
we didn't get them in time to put them
in the calendar they're actually in the
paper calendar at least i get it nailed
uh for next monday
right it's correct on the paper one and
it's some place it confused me because
well
it probably doesn't even matter but
in some part of the website now that we
have multiple places to have an
electronic calendar which i like
um it was listed incorrectly but
i don't i think i may be the only person
who
noticed that
i don't know
things to talk about while we're waiting
i don't know yes but
it
it was a mistake i wouldn't like i said
the monday is inconvenient because you
have to announce you have to get things
in the calendar a week and a half in
advance
so i only had a week on that
oh i see a hand up
nope that's miriam
all right
why do we have a pfast
[Music]
um
there is a
an issue with the connectivity
through the posting process that
the it people have been working on for
the past three to four weeks it's still
not resolved
sometimes things are showing up on the
docket
that
we have made corrections to in the paper
calendar
and so there's actually been a
several comments this morning from the
general court's
i.t department on
trying to address this so if you
go by the paper calendar uh the docket
on occasion may be incorrect but that it
is working on it
thank you that's very helpful you're
both okay it's good to know we're not
the only ones who are confused
hello yes
okay you can come in on the public link
and i'll bring you in to participate
okay uh sorry
mm-hmm
here i'd like to also thank you for your
incredible um
meteorological skills
as far as not having us stuck in
meetings when it's 60 degrees out for
the next three days
we will enjoy thursday wednesday and
thursday on our own
and friday is supposed to have a high of
64 down
thursday and friday
[Music]
you could be home today
well today is cooler so we might as well
be here
what is sonny
we actually haven't had to drive through
a lot of snow
a little bit
we've had no snow
okay why don't can can you join us next
well
um this is this is getting ridiculous
yeah
that's
it maybe it's you because the um
we've had people
attending the meeting all day
okay well maybe you're
probably it is okay
okay
we'll see we'll see if we can uh
arrange something for monday are you
next monday would that work for you
probably about the same time to
3 o'clock
okay i will uh
see if we can uh
we'll plan on that where we have some
attendance in the love so you don't need
a
[Music]
okay
okay thank you
bye
we have technical difficulties
representative wyler's computer doesn't
want to join up to any zoom
so
he will be joining us next monday
afternoon
to
top off our
the rest of our session
i think
i think that's all for today
sure looks like it looks like it here
okay unless somebody else has something
something important we'll uh close for
the day and thank you for very
productive
thank you madam chair
thank you madam